on trouve pour les copains des places
mais d'un autre côté c'est vrai que
il va il va avoir du poids pour aider un
premier ministre pour régler un certain
nombre de problèmes qui sont lourds
viennent parler tout à l'heure des
enjeux de l'environnement et des des
objectifs de la COP de la qui est en
train de se tenir
la situation de la RATP aujourd'hui elle
est déplorable le on a moins de
moins de fréquences de métro
il y a les grands chantiers dans la
perspective du Grand Paris et des Jeux
Olympiques donc il a il a des
responsabilités énormes est-ce que
il a la volonté je crois qu'il a de
mettre son poids ses capacités au
service d'un projet nouveau de transport
public si c'est si c'est ainsi ce n'est
pas une mauvaise chose ce n'est pas une
mauvaise chose pour vous non plus
William tais Jean Castex à la tête de là
RATP alors qu'il y a bien sûr un certain
nombre de grands projets à mener
notamment dans avec l'objectif des JO et
puis il y a aussi tout ce climat social
très compliqué à la RATP avec bien des
personnels qui vont faire grève demain
et qui dénonce des conditions de travail
dégradé du matériel vétuste
l'allongement des journées etc etc un
vrai problème à la RATP oui oui je suis
plutôt d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
moi je pense que le problème du copinage
bon on peut on peut le critiquer mais le
véritable problème du copinage c'est
quand on met des personnes qui sont pas
qualifiées qui sont nulles à ces postes
là alors que j'encaisse à plusieurs
qualités notamment pour répondre à la
question de la RATP il a été premier
ministre et donc du coup il est lignes
direct avec le président de la
République si par K il doit soulever
quelques enjeux il a une connaissance du
monde politique et institutionnel qui
est très importante mon avis que ça
allait poser quand même des problèmes
notamment pour qu'il rentre au contact
avec ses anciens ministres voilà il y a
peut-être quand même des sujets il y a
des sujets mais après il y a un deuxième
point moi je trouve qui est intéressant
avec le profil spécifique de Jean Castex
c'est que j'en Castex avait été nommé
Premier ministre par Macron notamment
parce qu'il a un profil consensuel qui
était capable de dialoguer à la fois que
les corps intermédiaires les élus locaux
et avec différents profils donc c'est à
dire qu'ils seront en capacité à la RATP
dialoguer avec les élus locaux comme
Valérie Pécresse la région de France etc
les différentes mairies mais également
avec les partenaires sociaux parce qu'il
est plutôt bon dans le dialogue social
et je pense que c'est un point qui est
intéressant le troisième point c'est
qu'en fait il a un profil plutôt
administratif et donc il a dû géré avant
d'être Premier ministre plusieurs postes
spécifiques comme stratagère général
adjoint l'Élysée etc donc il a le profil
pour gérer ça
aussi la difficulté et je pense que
c'est toujours essentiel sur ce point-là
c'est pas les personnes c'est quelle est
la ligne qu'on veut porter pour la RATP
et quelle est notre projet pour la RATP
il y a les problématiques de salaire et
je pense que les salaires en France sont
trop faibles mais quel est le moyen en
France pour permettre en fait
d'augmenter les salaires le seul moyen
qu'on a pour augmenter les salaires mais
avec la RATP c'est d'augmenter la
productivité à faire de faire en sorte
que en fait vous allez suivre le cours
de l'offre du marché et tant qu'on ne
pensera pas comme ça on sera pas à être
développement de l'offre on se passera
pas à une question de rentabilité parce
que l'État ne pourra pas payer Adidas
metternam ou les usagers ne voudront pas
payer un passe Navigo qui est beaucoup
plus important et bah c'est cette clé-là
notamment qui est portée et ce qui est
en capacité de le faire je pense qu'il a
la statue et plusieurs capacités pour le
faire mais on attend aujourd'hui quel
est son offre politique et qu'elle est
saline pour développer à TP alors on va
jouer à ça que si
je fais pour ce plateau mais peut-être
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire William test sur le fait
qu'il faille augmenter les salaires mais
pour cela augmenter la productivité la
productivité à la RATP elle est déjà
importante elle est ce que lui il se dit
un certain nombre certains nombre de
choses le travail dans les bus et dans
les métros aujourd'hui c'est pas un
travail facile ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que le fait que les salaires
ne soient pas suffisamment élevés bah
fait qu'on ne trouve pas
suffisamment de de de gens qui vont
d'autre part il y a un gros effort à
faire sur la formation des chauffeurs
l'eau sur les technologies nouvelles etc
donc je ne suis pas contre par contre il
y a il y a un autre sujet qui ne
dépendra pas directement de lui mais
quand même un peu parce que il devra
l'affronter c'est l'application des
Directives Européennes d'ouverture à la
concurrence qui selon moi n'est pas une
bonne chose mais si il peut contrer cela
et et de maintenir en quelque sorte
entre guillemets un monopole de la RATP
pour le métro et les bus je pense ce
sera très bon monopole concurrence
William tell pour conclure ce débat
je suis plutôt pour pour la concurrence
mais
pas sur la RATP comme c'est l'Union
européenne qui propose la concurrence
j'ai de plus en plus de doute parce qu'à
chaque fois que l'Union européenne a
refusé les fusions de grandes
entreprises et a proposé le plus tôt la
concurrence dans certains services
publics on a vu une catastrophe
notamment EDF donc je pense que sur les
sujets 10 stratégiques transports
energiques etc je pense qu'il faut pas
avoir la concurrence au moins le temps
que l'État fasse les investissements
nécessaires pour qu'on rattrape notre
retard notamment sur le parc etc on va
vous mettre d'accord sur tout ça cet
après-midi l'un et l'autre chose
merci beaucoup Patrick et Yarrick merci
beaucoup William t'aide à voir participé
à ce face à face tout de suite on va
rejoindre Quentin Calmet dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat on est à quelques
secondes de l'ouverture de cette séance
de question au gouvernement Quentin
voilà un mot sur l'ambiance Tam puisque
nous sommes en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle qu'on est donc au premier
âge c'est littéralement le cas pour voir
ce qui se passe dans l'hémicycle et vous
voyez ici au premier rang là dans ce
cercle intérieur de l'hémicycle les
ministres qui sont en train de
s'installer en nombre et on voit Franck
Riester ici qui est pour l'instant seul
sur le banc des ministres où va
s'installer et Elisabeth borne d'un
instant à l'autre le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement qui est
d'habitude toujours à la gauche
d'Elisabeth borne qui est donc pas
encore arrivé dans l'hémicycle on va
Christophe Béchu Gabriel Attal Clément
bonne Gérald Darmanin pape and Jay ils
sont très nombreux aujourd'hui encore à
la séance des questions du gouvernement
du Sénat un mot sur les 16 questions que
on attend à partir de 15 heures donc
dans quelques secondes on a retenu et
bien ces thèmes liés à la cop27 qui se
tient en Égypte cette semaine et la
semaine prochaine on voit que certains
groupes politiques vont poser des
questions directement liées à la
transition écologique par exemple les
centristes vont s'interroger sur la
formation au métier la transition
écologique quand les marcheurs le groupe
RDPI ont dit au Sénat vont interroger le
gouvernement sur la pollution
industrielle avec on l'a entendu cette
semaine le gouvernement en tout cas le
chef de l'État qui demande à ses
industries de réduire leur pollution
mais on va voir aussi des questions sur
le ferroviaire également une myriade
d'autres sujets d'actualité que ce soit
par exemple la situation des services
pédiatrique à l'Hôpital ou encore
l'organisation d'événements culturel en
marge et Jo 2024 ou encore la réforme du
lycée professionnel ou encore la
question de l'Iran on voit comme ça
toute une série de questions très
variées cette semaine alors que le
président de séance est en train de
faire le chemin entre le cabinet de
départ et les mystiques et elle a pu
voir arriver dans l'hémicycle juste
derrière moi donc on voit tout et c'est
sujet et aussi un autre grand thème
cette semaine encore à la question des
collectivités locales au cœur encore une
fois des questions des sénateurs on va
les questions sur le financement des
collectivités locales et au total comme
cela trois questions sur la situation de
ces collectivités alors que la séance va
commencer d'un instant à l'autre et que
effectivement le président de séance
rentre dans les mythique voilà le
silence se fait tout le monde se lève et
c'est Pierre Laurent le sénateur
vice-président communiste de Paris qui
va présider cette séance d'élection
d'actualité au Gouvernement cette
semaine et voilà la séance qui a
commencé
[Musique]
pas d'observation
le procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous prie d'excuser le président du
Sénat en déplacement à Colombelles les
deux églises
je vous rappelle
[Applaudissements]
je vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmis en direct sur Public Sénat et
sur notre site internet au nom du bureau
du Sénat appelle chacun de vous mes
chers collègues à observer au cours de
nos échanges l'une des valeurs
essentielles du Sénat le respect qu'il
s'agisse du respect des uns et des
autres ou de celui du temps de parole
la parole est à Madame Christine Labarde
pour le groupe républicain
madame la Première ministre cette
question vous adressée car elle concerne
plusieurs membres de votre gouvernement
et je vois qui a été choisi pour me
répondre quelqu'un qui n'a pas assisté
au débat dont il va être question un de
nos illustres prédécesseurs sur ses
bancs a dit que la forme c'est le fond
qui remonte à la surface alors ma
question va être en deux temps tout
d'abord la forme comment pouvez-vous
oser redéposer par l'intermédiaire d'un
49-3 une disposition qui a été rejetée
par les deux assemblées une première
fois à l'Assemblée nationale une
deuxième fois au Sénat et cette
disposition d'ailleurs a été déposée en
catimini car elle ne figurerait pas dans
les amendements retenus dans la première
version du texte et on l'a vu arriver
dans le texte consolidé envoyé le jeudi
matin aux assemblées je parle là des
contrats de confiance au contrat de
Cahors et donc j'en arrive maintenant à
ma question sur le fond madame la
Première ministre cette disposition
vatale être remise une fois que le Sénat
leur a supprimé lors de l'étude de la du
PLF pour 2023 dont le 49-3 qui sera de
nouveau proposer à l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'avare de quoi s'agit-il je
pense que vous faites référence à
l'article 23
et à un processus législatif que je
souhaite reprendre quelques instants
maman de
du début de ce quinquennat la première
ministre a souhaité que la nature des
relations que nous puissions engager
avec les associations d'élus change de
nature et ça a donné lieu à une
rédaction initiale celle effectivement
d'un dispositif qui tournait le dos
contrat de Cahors qui supposait des
engagements individuels en préfecture
avec des trajectoires assorties de
sanctions qui étaient très automatisées
pour arriver un schéma passe à lui et
par toutes les associations des lieux
mais par certaines d'entre elles comme
étant une évolution du dispositif de
dialogue je pense en particulier
intercommunalité de France et la DCS et
la déesse pardon qui repose sur l'idée
d'arrêter un objectif global de dépenses
publiques dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
qu'à l'issue des comptes administratifs
2023 par strat on regarde où on en est
et qu'on puisse ensuite seulement s'il y
a des dépassements regardez à
l'intérieur de la strate les
collectivités qui dépassent
le problème c'est que ce dispositif dont
on a besoin pour crédibiliser la
trajectoire des finances publiques de la
France a été écarté dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques
il a été décidé dans le cadre du PLF de
réintroduire les articles dont nous
avions besoin pour crédibiliser cette
trajectoire des finances publiques et
très concrètement c'est une façon aussi
de reprovoquer le dialogue on peut pas
écarter d'un revers de main
j'ose
espérer
j'ose espérer
que ça n'est pas la nature de la
relation que vous aurez quand on va
entrer dans le détail de ces articles le
gouvernement est prêt sur ce sujet à
discuter mais il considère que la voix
d'un compromis à la fois sur les
finances des collectivités sur les
finances de l'état nécessite précisément
un travail de co-construction et le
balayer d'un revers de main ne peut pas
être une attitude responsable merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame Lavarde
comprendre des dotations de l'État pour
l'investissement des collectivités donc
vous mettiez même à maths le financement
de la transition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est maintenant au président
Jean-François Longeot pour le groupe
Union centriste merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du Travail et la
COP 27 c'est ouverte dimanche dernier à
sharm-el-sheik il s'agit d'un
rendez-vous déterminant pour l'avenir de
la planète nous ne pouvons que saluer
les engagements pris par l'Europe et la
France pour parvenir à la neutralité
carbone en 2050 atteindre cet objectif
va nécessiter
des compétences tu es l'objectif de ma
question celle des ressources humaines
et de la transition si nous ne prenons
pas assez au sérieux l'enjeu de la
formation la transition écologique
pourrait demain se heurter à une pénurie
de savoir-faire dans notre pays en ce
moment même des soudeurs américains
réparent les défauts de corrosion sous
contrainte de notre parc nucléaire car
nous n'avons pas assez de ressources
humaines pour y parvenir seul dans des
délais resserrés actuels parmi les
problématiques les plus parlantes au
sujet de la pénurie de compétences on
sait que le secteur des transports est
l'un des gros émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre le ferroviaire va avoir un rôle
clé dans le verdissement de ce secteurs
or une étude prospective menée par
l'Observatoire des métiers de la
métallurgie a récemment démontré que
d'ici à 2030 le besoin en ingénieur
ferroviaire serait de près de 14000
ingénieurs nécessitant plus de 7900
nouveaux recrutement en tenant compte
des départs à la retraite
ce qui signifie que devrait sortir des
formations supérieures spécialisées dans
le ferroviaire environ 790 ingénieurs
par an alors ils n'en sort aujourd'hui
que 250 la question étant l'occurrence
quantitative mais elle est aussi
qualitative il faut former à la
décarbonation c'est particulièrement
vrai dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables du nucléaire ou encore de
l'agriculture telle était d'ailleurs le
message de l'appel des étudiants de
l'AgroParisTech il déplorait ne pas être
formé à la gros écologie monsieur le
ministre à l'heure de la COP 27 notre
système de formation initiale et
continue a-t-il bien pris en compte
l'enjeu de la transition
environnementale si oui comment merci
merci chers collègues la parole et à
Monsieur Olivier dussoque ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le Président Longeot
d'abord merci de rappeler par votre
question l'importance des transitions
l'importance des travaux mené leur de la
cop27 mais pour vous répondre en deux
points un premier point simplement pour
dire que vous avez mille fois raison sur
ce qui concerne la formation initiale et
la nécessité qu'elle soit orientée vers
l'accompagnement des transitions et en
particulier la transition écologique mon
collègue ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec madame la ministre
déléguée en charge de la formation
professionnelle pourrait vous dire tout
ce qui est fait en matière de
réorientation de la formation de
réorientation et de réforme de la loi
professionnelle justement pour avoir des
formations qualifiantes qui permettent
d'aborder l'avenir c'est vrai pour les
études secondaires c'est vrai pour les
études supérieures à madame la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur il veille
aussi faire en sorte que notre appareil
de formation initiale intègre pleinement
les besoins de formation que vous avez
évoqué mais au-delà de la formation
initiale nous devons aussi penser
des transitions pour l'ensemble des
entreprises et l'ensemble des salariés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes aussi extrêmement attentifs à ce
que les entreprises puissent accompagner
la transition en leur sang vous avez
évoqué le secteur du nucléaire vous avez
évoqué l'agriculture vous allez le
secteur de l'hydrogène et des transports
le secteur de l'automobile aussi est
particulièrement concerné et nous donc
faire en sorte par la formation continue
par les dispositifs de transition de
transition collective par les
dispositifs de formation des salariés
d'accompagner cette transition pour que
celles et ceux qui ont été formées sur
des techniques qui étaient des
techniques d'excellence il y a 10 ans 15
ans 20 ans puisse être à nouveau formé
monté pouvoir monter en qualification et
accompagner ces transition dans le cadre
de la loi de finance pour 2023 vous
aurez l'occasion de constater dans les
prochains jours plus de 350 millions
d'euros ont été prévus pour réabonder le
Front national Pôle emploi sur son volet
formation le FNA formation pour financer
aussi les dispositifs de transition
collective et permettre dans le cas du
dialogue social que les branches
professionnelles se saisissent de ce
besoin de reclassement de formation et
d'apport de nouvelles qualifications de
nouvelles compétences à leurs salariés
et ainsi répondre aux enjeux de
transition que vous avez rappelé
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Gérard
laelec pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
Transports
dans le contexte où se réunit la cop27
il est bon de rappeler que les
transports représentent un tiers de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais pas en raison des politiques
publiques mais plutôt en raison de ce
que ne font pas de nos politiques
publiques tout le monde s'accorde pour
reconnaître que pour changer de cap
atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 et doubler la part des ferroviaire
d'ici 2030 ce n'est pas de mesurer dont
nous avons besoin mais au contraire
d'une grande ambition publique il nous
faut tout à la fois développer le frais
de ferroviaire assurer la remise à
niveau de notre réseau par un tout autre
contrat de performance ou encore
pourquoi pas développer les trains de
nuit donc la marge de progression est
gigantesque comme la rappeler et nous le
rappelle constamment les mouvements des
usagers la désertion de nos territoires
il est difficultés de recrutement et
précisément s'il est un thème sur lequel
on peut agir c'est bien sur le thème des
transports une majorité politique existe
pour dégager des moyens supplémentaires
à la fois au Sénat comme en atteste les
divers rapport adopté ici mais aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale ou un amendement
au budget proposant 3 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour le ferroviaire a
été adopté disons-le avec des voix de
gauche et des voies de droite le
gouvernement est-il prêt à s'emparer de
cette situation inédite d'une majorité
politique possible pour dégager des
moyens afin de donner un nouvel élan au
transport ferroviaire merci
merci la parole
à Monsieur le Ministre de transforme
monsieur Clément bonne
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Laennec vous avez raison
d'insister sur cette priorité je crois
vous l'avez exprimé dans le ton même de
votre question elle est largement
partagée il y a un consensus à la fois
pour rappeler les chiffres que vous avez
indiqué les sectes le transport pardon
c'est 30 % des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et notre consommation
énergétique et donc nous devons lui
donner une priorité très forte notamment
dans le transport ferroviaire et dans le
report d'autres modes de transport vers
le ferroviaire le budget qui sera soumis
à votre débat dans quelques jours porte
un effort extrêmement important en
faveur des transports et notamment les
transports publics je tiens à le redire
parce que c'est parfois un peu oublié
dans notre débat quand nous avons plus
de la moitié de l'effort de l'État au
total 12 milliards d'euros 6,6 pour le
transport ferroviaire qui est consacré
précisément au train au transport public
je ne crois je crois que ce ne sont pas
exactement ni des mesures ni des
cacahuètes budgétaires quand nous avons
plus de 85% du programme budgétaire des
transports qui sont consacrés pour la
première fois au transport ferroviaire
je crois que nous sommes aussi dans une
action importante vous avez évoqué un
certain nombre dans le domaine plus
précis je pense aux fraises nous avons
un plan d'un milliard d'euros sur 6 ans
qui est consacré au fret les petites
lignes qui vous sont chères et qui sont
si importantes c'est pour la première
fois le premier ministre Jean Castex
avait initié d'ailleurs ce mouvement ce
sont les protocoles pour préaler 6
milliards d'euros qui sont aujourd'hui
signés avec les régions pour investir
sur plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de
lignes près de 6000 d'ores et déjà
devons-nous prolonger amplifier cet
effort ensemble oui c'est exactement la
démarche transpartisane que vous avez
décrite qui allait occasion de se
déployer dans le cadre du comité du
Conseil par l'orientation des
infrastructures laquelle participent
plusieurs membres du Sénat comme
plusieurs membres de l'Assemblée
nationale toute sensibilité confondues
nous aurons ces travaux d'ici à la fin
de l'année et sur cette base nous
pourrons aussi définir une programmation
des moyens et des priorités très claires
pour le ferroviaire en particulier
j'insiste sur un point j'insiste sur un
point qui est essentiel c'est que le
réseau ferroviaire doit être absolument
prioritaire dans nos choix budgétaires
et c'est en plus la responsabilité de
l'État du niveau national que d'investir
encore davantage dans ce réseau je veux
dire que nous avons quasiment le doublé
les crédits qui consacrer ces cinq
dernières années donc nous avons engagé
cette démarche nous irons plus loin et
nous le ferons ensemble merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur laelec merci
monsieur le ministre en tout cas il ne
faudrait pas que vous considériez qu'il
n'y a de majorité politique que lorsque
c'est le gouvernement qui décide vous
avez la chance de disposer de
dispositions parlementaires saisissons
je pense l'occasion pour avancer en ce
moment
merci chers collègues la parole au
président Alain Richard pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie les
entreprises industrielles de quelques
secteurs fortement utilisateurs
d'énergie concentrent une part
importante des émissions gaz à effet de
serre celle qui opère en France ne font
pas exception mais nous savons tous que
les décennies passées ont vu certaines
industries disparaitrent et ce n'est
évidemment pas de ce côté-là qui est la
solution
pour l'avenir la réduction efficace de
nos émissions ne peut pas se traduire
par une nouvelle désindustrialisation et
par un gonflement de nos importations
les responsables de ces entreprises ont
pour beaucoup d'entre eux progressé dans
leur transformation et commencer à
obtenir des résultats le rythme de
baisse les émissions des industriels
français se comparent honorablement à
celui de leur concurrents de l'Union
européenne et des grands pays développés
mais il faut aller plus vite le
président de la République a organisé
une réflexion partagée avec ses
dirigeants pour définir ensemble le
meilleur programme d'action le thème
était comment répondre à l'urgence
climatique et soutenir des industries
modernisées créatives et compétitive
pour produire de la richesse et
développer de l'emploi qualifiée en
France Monsieur le Ministre quelles sont
les grands engagements que le
gouvernement veut obtenir de nos
partenaires industriels et quels sont
les grands axes du programme de soutien
que vous présenter prochainement pour
relever ce défi
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Alain Richard je vais vous
raconter une histoire
[Musique]
soit à dormir debout
une histoire à rêver de vous
c'est celle du site de Solvay que l'on
visiter ce matin avec le ministre de
l'Industrie Roland Lescure un site qui a
un siècle d'histoire industrielle
derrière lui un site qui produit des
produits chimiques du carbonate de soude
du bicarbonate de soude avec comme
énergie du charbon importé de Russie un
site donc émet beaucoup de CO2 qui a des
problèmes de compétitivité et qui
aujourd'hui ne répond plus au standards
les plus innovants et à nos exigences
environnementales ce site est en train
d'opérer une révolution climatique et
industrielle il va transformer son
énergie charbon en utilisant les déchets
recyclables de tout le bassin tout le
bassin géographique pour réduire son
empreinte carbone améliorer sa
compétitivité et ouvrir un nouveau
siècle d'histoire industriel pour le
site de Solvay et bien je veux rendre
hommage aux ouvriers aux ingénieurs aux
techniciens aux entrepreneurs un Solvay
qui opère cette révolution industrielle
et environnementale cette décarbonation
cette histoire a rêvé debout elle doit
être l'histoire de tous les grands sites
industriels français et notamment des 56
industriels que le Président de la
République a choisi auquel nous allons
apporter 5 milliards d'euros d'aide
immédiatement et 5 milliards d'euros
d'aide complémentaires si jamais nous
suivent dans cet objectif de
décarbonation pour que nous ayons demain
l'industrie mondiale la plus décarbonée
de la planète voilà une grande ambition
pour la France et voilà l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés avec le président
de la République et pour tenir cet
objectif non seulement nous allons
accompagner chacun de ces 56 mais nous
allons le compléter de deux décisions la
première c'est évidemment accompagner
toutes ces entreprises dans les mois qui
viennent pour faire face à l'explosion
leur facture d'énergie et pour qu'elle
puisse accomplir cette transition en
ayant le soutien de l'État
l'accompagnement de l'État et la
deuxième décision c'est accélérer la
mise en place la taxe carbone aux
frontières parce que la décarbonation de
notre industrie qui construira l'avenir
industriel français doit se faire aussi
sur la base d'une équité de concurrence
en évitant d'importer des produits qui
eux continuent à polluer et qui viennent
du dehors des frontières de l'Europe
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
monsieur le Président pas de pas de
réplique
bien je vais passer maintenant la parole
à notre collègue Emilienne Poumirol pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur miso la santé et de
la prévention soins des programmés faute
de lit transfert hors région de certains
patients enfants hospitalisés dans des
services adultes les services de
pédiatrie sont saturés douleurs cris de
détresse il y a quelques jours et la
situation tendue en pédiatrie n'est que
l'arbre qui cache la forêt car c'est
tout l'hôpital public qui est en voie
d'effondrement le vrai problème est
structurel les conditions de travail
amènent les personnels à quitter
l'hôpital et des services y compris aux
urgences doivent être fermées
face à cette situation vous avez annoncé
un plan pour soutenir les services en
tension de l'hôpital de 150 millions
d'euros puis de 400 millions d'euros et
enfin hier au détour du débat sur le
pnfss de 556 millions d'euros au total
et ce sans aucune nouvelle recette ces
enveloppes successives bien que
bienvenus sont l'illustration de votre
pilotage à la petite semaine malgré
votre communication lambda met deux fois
inférieur à l'inflation et de fait le
gouvernement réduit les moyens du
système de soins et l'hôpital public
année la première victime alors monsieur
le ministre a quand une réponse pérenne
et d'envergure pour l'hôpital public
merci chers collègues la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé de la
prévention Monsieur François Braun
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice pomirol vous imaginez bien et
vous le savez je suis de très près la
situation des services de pédiatrie plus
généralement la situation également de
notre hôpital public et de ses
difficultés
je vous assurer que l'ensemble des
moyens disponibles sont mobilisés pour
faire face à cette nouvelle crise et à
cette épidémie de bronchiolite santé
publique France d'ailleurs ce matin nous
indiquait que c'est une épidémie qui
dépasse les pics épidémiques que nous
avons connues depuis plus de 10 ans
d'ailleurs pour accompagner cette cette
information j'ai décidé ce matin en
complément de tout ce qui était déjà
mobilisé de déclencher le plan hors-sant
spécifique à cette épidémie pour
renforcer encore les moyens des ARS et
permettre que l'ensemble de l'hôpital
puisse se concentrer sur ce problème
particulièrement aigu aujourd'hui
des mesures d'urgence ont été prises et
le gouvernement et je remercie le Sénat
à amené effectivement des moyens
financiers supplémentaires pour faire
face à ces difficultés mais je vous
rejoins lorsque vous dites que le
problème est plus structurel au sein de
notre hôpital public et de notre système
de santé et le ministère de la Santé de
la prévention ne doit pas et ne sera pas
uniquement un ministère de crise mais un
ministère de refonder notre système de
santé dans son ensemble c'est d'ailleurs
tout l'enjeu du Conseil national de la
refondation en santé qui a voulu le
président de la République
j'ai commencé à rencontrer depuis une
semaine l'ensemble des professionnels
bien sûr de la pédiatrie mais l'ensemble
des professionnels de l'hôpital
également ce qui concerne plus
spécifiquement la pédiatrie nous
travaillons aux Assises de la pédiatrie
et de la santé de l'enfant puisque tout
le chant de la santé de l'enfant mérite
d'être réformé nous aboutirons au
printemps avec une feuille de route pour
les années à venir sur un centre de la
santé de l'enfant dans les mêmes dates
nous aurons les résultats des différents
CNR territoriaux et nationaux sur la
santé pour la refondation de notre
système de santé pour qu'il soit basé
non plus sur l'offre de soins mais bien
sur la réponse aux besoins de santé de
la population française je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues allez-y
monsieur le ministre ne veut pas se
cacher derrière l'épidémie de
bronchiolite pour parler des problèmes
actuels vous avez fait des choix et ses
choix il faut maintenant les assumer
vous avez décidé de faire porter les
17,7 milliards d'euros de la dette covid
sur la sécurité sociale créant cette
année sont déficit vous avez décidé
d'exonération de cotisations qui sont
passées en 5 ans de 39 à 71 milliards
mais vous refusez dans le même temps
toutes les propositions que nous avons
pu vous faire pour trouver de nouvelles
recettes c'est donc que vous faites le
choix délibéré du déficit pour la
sécurité sociale et ce peut-être ou sans
doute au profit du système primaire but
lucratif alors monsieur le ministre nous
sommes croisés des chemins soit vous
décidez d'abandonner l'hôpital public
soit vous engagez enfin cette réforme
structurelle le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains de son côté
éclaire et réclamer une réforme urgente
et pérenne tenant compte du ratio
patient personnel soignant sur tous les
territoires
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant la parole est notre
collègue Ghislaine Pantel pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
vous êtes interpellé intervalles
réguliers dans cette hémicycle sur les
ressources dont dispose des
collectivités territoriales pour
alimenter leur budget et assurer le bon
fonctionnement des services publics
locaux après la suppression progressive
de la taxe d'habitation au cours du
premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron l'année
2023 doit être marquée par une nouvelle
étape dans la transformation de la
fiscalité locale avec la suppression de
la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises la CVAE doit donc être
supprimée après avoir vu son taux divisé
par deux en 2021 naturellement des
mécanismes de compensation voient
systématiquement le jour avec plus ou
moins des réactivité comme le transfert
de la part départementale de la taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties aux
communes ainsi que l'ajout d'un
coefficient correcteur dans les cas où
le transfert ne suffit pas
or plusieurs
arguments viennent se percuter avec ce
système de suppression compensation si
l'intention de ce gouvernement est
d'enclenché une vraie décentralisation
la disparition de taxes doit pas avoir
pour effet de restreindre les ressources
fiscales des collectivités territoriales
au point d'entraver leur libre
administration et leur développement
le contexte inflationniste nous prouve
que les dotations de l'État qui par
définition ne sont pas dynamiques ne
peuvent se satisfaire les besoins en
fonctionnement et investissement des
collectivités un exemple la commune de
Montbel en Lozère perçoit une DGF de
25000 euros alors que le fonctionnement
de l'école lui coûte 20.000 euros par an
c'est Costa sont faits depuis bien
longtemps il est maintenant nécessaire
de réinventer à la fois les concours
financiers de l'État et la fiscalité
locale pour que les communes et
collectivités rurales puissent se
développer accueillir de nouvelles
populations et faciliter la création
d'entreprise en somme le gouvernement
a-t-il l'intention d'impulser une
réflexion globale pour un système plus
équilibré de ressources pour les
collectivités et notamment les plus
rurales je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame
Caroline cailleux ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Pantel vous m'interrogez sur
l'évolution des ressources des
collectivités locales face aux
suppressions des impôts locaux et au
montant de la DGF des petites communes
je voudrais tout d'abord faire un rappel
à savoir que les suppressions d'impôts
sont une bonne chose pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français car elle servent à
leur augmenter et d'autre part elles
permettent d'améliorer la compétitivité
des entreprises du côté des
collectivités locales pour la taxe
d'habitation comme pour la CVAE il y a
des compensations à l'Europe qui sont
prévues elles seront dynamiques en clair
pour revenir sur la CVAE
à la demande des associations d'élus
nous leur avons consacré une part de TVA
notamment vous le voyez la volonté du
gouvernement c'est bien de préserver
l'autonomie des collectivités et j'y
suis moi-même personnellement attaché en
ce qui concerne la dotation globale de
fonctionnement après la forte baisse ou
le mandat de François Hollande la DGF a
été stabilisée à partir de 2018 avec le
PLF 2023 ce sont 320 millions d'euros
qui sont rajoutés pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans dont 200 millions d'euros
de hausse pour la dotation de solidarité
rurale dont bénéficieront les communes
de Lozère c'est un changement important
demandé par de nombreux élus locaux et
de parlementaires depuis de nombreuses
années alors faut-il aller encore plus
loin je sais que la Cour des comptes a
proposé au Sénat une réflexion sont très
ambitieuses et pour ce sujet comme pour
tout ce qui concerne nos collectivités
je reste évidemment à l'écoute de la
chambre des territoires et de vos
propositions avant de conclure je
voudrais rappeler néanmoins que au-delà
des concours financiers de l'État le
gouvernement a mis en place une
politique ambitieuse pour accompagner et
soutenir nos territoires ruraux je pense
à l'agenda rural et qui en est parfaite
exemple tout comme le programme petite
ville de demain
[Musique]
merci
mais le respect du temps de parole fait
partie de notre règle du jeu commune
la parole à notre collègue Monique de
Marco pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
parlons festival
j'avoue être un peu perdu je ne sais
plus si je dois m'adresser au ministre
de l'intérieur ou à vous madame la
ministre de la Culture pourquoi le 25
octobre le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Darmanin a présenté les
dispositifs de sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique de 2024 près
de 45000 policiers gendarmes seraient
mobilisés de juillet à septembre
face à l'ampleur de ce dispositif il a
évoqué je cite la possible annulation ou
le report de tous les événements en
France qui demandent des unités de force
mobile
à l'heure des programmations des
organisateurs de festivals les syndicats
les centaines de milliers de
travailleurs du secteur et les millions
de spectateurs s'inquiètent faute de
service de sécurité suffisants les
festivals seront-ils sacrifiés pour les
Jeux Olympiques
les festivals sont l'image de la France
et de son exception culturelle il
garantissent une offre culturelle
diversifiée dans l'ensemble du
territoire en attirant des millions de
personnes leur retombées financière sont
également conséquentes par exemple les
Francofolies de La Rochelle génèrent 11
millions d'euros le Festival d'Avignon
50 millions d'euros et les fêtes de
Bayonne attirent chaque année un million
de personnes si l'activité financière
festivalière est annulé qui assurera les
conséquences financières
l'annulation ou le report serait
catastrophique pour un secteur qui peine
à se remettre de la pandémie la culture
ne doit pas être une nouvelle fois la
variable d'ajustement de décision de
nationale
vous avez tenu une réunion avec les
acteurs de la filière le 2 novembre qui
n'a pas permis de répondre à leurs
inquiétudes vous n'avez apporté ni
solution ni réponse il ne suffit pas
madame la ministre de dire que vous êtes
consciente des enjeux nous voulons
savoir qui sera concerné quand comment
et dans quelle mesure comme tous les
acteurs du spectacle vivant et de la
musique nous attendons des réponses
claires et des engagements je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à Madame Rima Abdul Malak
ministre de la Culture
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de Marco vous avez raison de
dire que la France est une terre de
festivals que c'est une partie
importante de l'ADN culturel de la
France notamment l'été et vous avez
raison de mentionner toutes les
retombées économiques pour les
territoires qui sont majeurs mais nous
savons aussi que l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques c'est un moment exceptionnel
hors norme c'est une fois par siècle ça
va être un grand moment festif et
populaire qui nécessite une organisation
hors-norme évidemment une sécurisation
particulièrement renforcée or les
festivals aussi ont besoin d'être
sécurisés les festivals mobilisent pour
les très très grands festivals qui
mobilisent des dizaines de milliers de
personnes des unités de force mobile
donc le travail que nous sommes en train
de faire avec Gérald Darmanin et Amélie
oudia Castéra c'est ce travail fin au
cas par cas des situations les plus
impactées pour chercher les solutions
pour voir comment concilier le mieux
possible cette vitalité naturel des
festivals et les nécessités de
sécurisation pour eux comme pour les
Jeux olympiques mais il y a aussi
l'enjeu des moyens techniques des
personnels des tensions sur les
bénévoles sur les transports des
spectateurs c'est un ensemble de
paramètres en réalité qui impactent les
festivals et qui nécessitent un travail
au cas par cas face par phase avec les
professionnels vous l'avez dit je les ai
reçus assez longuement je poursuis le
travail en bilatérale si je puis dire
avec chacun d'entre eux et avec leurs
syndicats d'organisation professionnelle
nous sommes en train dans les semaines
qui viennent nous verrons se dessiner
certaines solutions et je pourrai vous
en faire part nous sommes pleinement
conscients de cette nécessité de
concilier la force des Jeux Olympiques
et la force des festivals
je vous remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Pierre-Jean verzelen pour le
groupe Les Indépendants
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre des Transports que
se passe-t-il à la SNCF que va faire la
SNCF nous savons bien que vous n'êtes
pas le président de cette entreprise
publique mais enfin l'État en est
l'actionnaire unique
en général 5% des trains annulés c'est
ce qu'on appelle un trafic normal à la
SNCF mais nous constatons tous que
depuis quelques semaines et de quelques
mois la situation se dégrade je vais
prendre l'exemple d'une région que je
connais bien celle des Hauts de France
en plus des retard depuis le mois
d'avril c'est prêt d'un train sur 10 en
moyenne et chaque jour qui est annulé ce
qui crée un climat de tension et
d'anxiété pour les usagers et évidemment
et notamment ceux qui travaillent la
raison principale qui est invoquée c'est
le manque de personnel on peut aussi et
notre collègue glacé pointer le
sous-investissement chronique dans le
réseau secondaire depuis 30 ans
ce manque d'anticipation de la part de
dirigeants d'un grand groupe public
paraît aberrant comment en sommes-nous
arrivés là et comment la situation va se
rétablir
monsieur le ministre la SNCF prend de
plein fouet la hausse des prix
d'électricité quid du bouclier tarifaire
pour protéger les voyageurs de la hausse
du prix des billets
déjà que nous savons que le train n'est
pas forcément plus attractif que la
voiture ou l'avion au moment où la
France prend des engagements à la cop27
on ne peut pas se satisfaire que le
moyen de transport le plus écoles en CO2
soit financièrement le moins intéressant
j'ajoute que les régions en charge des
TER sont censés je dis bien censés avoir
un dialogue quotidien avec la SNCF elles
sont confrontées à un manque de
transparence de la part de l'entreprise
et aussi de ce qu'on peut appeler le
Triangle des Bermudes de la SNCF c'est à
dire une organisation enfin une
désorganisation plutôt où il y a
tellement d'interlocuteurs on ne sait
plus qui fait quoi on ne sait plus qui
vous répond et personne ne sait vous
dire oui ou non monsieur le ministre
comment retrouver cette relation de
confiance entre les régions et la SNCF
comment rétablir l'offre de train et
comment la SNCF va répercuter ou pas la
hausse du coût de l'énergie sur le prix
des billets merci
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
Clément bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vergelen vous avez raison je
n'ai pas l'habitude de fuir mes
responsabilités nous parlons un grand
service public qui l'entreprise
entièrement public et donc cela ne peut
pas rester sans réponse ou faire face à
un quelconque désintérêt de la part de
l'État c'est la raison pour laquelle je
l'ai dit la situation les hauts de
France est inacceptable et nous avons eu
un entretien puisque les TER sont
effectivement la charge des régions avec
le président vis-à-vis Bertrand je me
suis rendu à l'île dès lundi et je me
suis sur entretenu hier avec le
président farando une nouvelle fois il y
a un effort exceptionnel de formation
qui est fait pour compenser ce que vous
avez décrit c'est-à-dire une pénurie de
conducteurs qui malheureusement parce
que cela fait partie des métiers en
tension ne concerne pas que la région
des Hauts de France mais concerne très
fortement très douloureusement les
usagers des Hauts de France aujourd'hui
il y a un plan qui a été tout à fait
exceptionnel qui a été mise en place ces
derniers mois qui prévoit en 2022 2023
le recrutement inédit de 440
collaborateurs TER en haut de France
mais j'ai demandé aux prises en pharaon
de ouf face à la gravité de la situation
un exceptionnel d'urgence et
d'accélération de ces recrutements par
tous les moyens possibles qui sera
présenté par l'entreprise dans les
prochains jours en lien avec la région
car cette situation ne peut rester sans
réponse je l'ai dit très honnêtement une
situation de cette nature ne se règle
pas en quelques jours elle ne se résout
pas totalement en quelques semaines mais
nous devons montrer les améliorations
visibles sérieuses dans les toutes
prochaines semaines pour les usagers
vous avez parlé aussi de la question
tarifaire cela doit mérite mérite pardon
quelques précisions d'abord les tarifs
qui sont justement ceux du TER et de
beaucoup de trains des quotidiens ne
relève pas de l'État les tarifs en
revanche qui sont ceux des trains à
grande vitesse ou des trains d'équilibre
du territoire sont de niveau national et
du ressort national c'est dans ce
contexte que j'ai demandé pour ces
trains à la SNF te mettre en place un
bouclier tarifaire qu'est ce que cela
signifie concrètement cela signifie que
nous devons d'abord agir pour réduire
les charges de la SNCF c'est ce que fait
l'état par les mesures que nous prenons
sur la maîtrise des coûts de l'énergie
qui a permis de réduire très fortement
le montant qu’évoquait devant le Sénat
le président farondu près de 2 milliards
d'euros nous ne sommes plus du tout dans
ces ordres de grandeur ensuite d'avoir
des hausses qui sont en toute état de
cause inférieure à l'inflation et
troisième point de préserver ceux qui
ont le plus besoin du train les ménages
modestes les utilisateurs réguliers
notamment pour le travail c'est pourquoi
j'ai demandé un effort tout particulier
sur les abonnements et sur les wigos ce
plan sera présenté là aussi dans
quelques jours par la SNCF je vous
remercie si Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Bruno Belin pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la France est à sec à sec
d'argent à sec do à sec d'électricité à
sec de gaz à sec de nucléaire à sec de
médecins et maintenant un sac de
certains médicaments
spasfon et gaviscon nous cherchons
amoxicilline et paracétamol aussi rare
que le pétrole en cette épidémie de
bronchiolite c'est dramatique ce sont
pourtant des médicaments matures peu
onéreux et essentiel tout au long de
l'année alors ma question monsieur le
ministre de la Santé est aussi simple
qu'elle inquiète les professionnels de
santé et les patients quelle est votre
stratégie pour que la France puisse
retrouver sa souveraineté sur les
produits de santé
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
François braune ministre de la Santé de
la prévention
Michel Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Bruno
Belin le président de la République a
fixé un cap lors du conseil stratégique
des industries de santé de 2021
réindustrialisé garantir notre capacité
d'approvisionnement et notre
souveraineté tout en maintenant un taux
de croissance de l'industrie du
médicament supérieur à 2%. nous avons
deux enjeux favoriser l'innovation
soutenir l'accès aux médicaments
innovants mais aussi maintenir l'accès à
des médicaments plus anciens mais
particulièrement
utile vous parliez du paracétamol c'est
bien sûr un enjeu majeur de santé
publique à ce titre des obligations ont
été renforcées pour les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur des
obligations au niveau du volume des
stocks
les obligations également au niveau des
moyens amoxicilline et difficile d'accès
alors que les autres formes
d'amoxicilline sont facilement
accessibles vous évoquez la bronchiolite
j'en profite et je suis obligé dans
cette semaine de l'antibiorésistance de
bien préciser que la bronchiolite est
une maladie virale sur laquelle il ne
faut pas de dés d'antibiotiques au
risque de développer
l'antibio-résistance
je suis bien sûr ces situations en temps
réel avec l'Agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament situation qui sont
complexes et j'ai demandé toute la
transparence aux industriels il est
difficile de faire la part des choses
entre les déficiences de produits actifs
et la efficience justement de capacité
d'emballage que ce soit le verre ou que
ce soit le carton nous avons un plan
comme vous le savez pénurie je ferais
bientôt le point là-dessus en ce qui
concerne le développement d'une filière
française de l'industrie du médicament
voulu là aussi par le Président de la
République je vous rappelle que dans le
cas du plan France 2030 7,5 milliards
d'euros ont été mis dans cette filière à
titre d'exemple et vous parliez du
paracétamol l'année prochaine ouvre en
Isère une usine qui va produire 10 000
tonnes de paracétamol par an pour en
couvrir largement le marché français je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Bolland
je prends avec de votre réponse monsieur
le ministre
et je pense que vous-même et votre
collègue Agnès firmerleau est de bonne
volonté
mais mais le sirop Tiffon c'est fini à
vouloir asphyxier le médicament et
surtout son prix merci depuis des années
à tuer une industrie nationale
stratégique le coût de la panne du
doliprane et révélateur d'une France
exsangue la réalité c'est Sanofi
incapable de faire avec ça la réalité
c'est des médicaments contingenté tous
les matins la réalité c'est un accès
plus compliqué à la santé c'est
une récession indiscutable de la
puissance santé de la France la
mascarade des masques à illustrer de
façon insoutenable cette impuissance
cette faiblesse
il faut réindustrialiser la France car
aujourd'hui ce sont des médicaments qui
manquent le combat pour la santé et donc
celui pour la vie passe par là je vous
remercie monsieur le président
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Rémi Cardon
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre les savoirs techniques
Emmanuel sont essentiels à notre
quotidien et à la réussite collective de
notre pays et pourtant lors de sa
présentation sur la réforme de la voix
professionnelle en septembre dernier le
président de la République a fait savoir
qu'il entendait réduire le nombre
d'heures dédiés au savoir fondamentaux
dans les lycées professionnels cela
n'est pas sérieux et pour preuve en
disant presque 1400 heures
d'enseignement ont été supprimés ils
restent aujourd'hui moins de deux heures
de français par semaine pour les Bac Pro
les heures d'enseignement font de en
réalité comme neige au soleil et on
pousse de plus en plus tôt les jeunes
dans les bras du marché du travail au
détriment de leur ouverture culturelle
et de leur émancipation
le manutentionnaire n'aurait pas besoin
de trop d'éloquence pour la base besogne
peu importe si cela le met en difficulté
pour défendre ses droits ou changer sa
carrière un ouvrier n'est pas fait pour
devenir poète ou encore professeur et
puis c'est bien connu s'il veut
s'insurger il aura la grève ou
l'abstention madame la Première ministre
les inégalités commencent dès la
naissance et avec cette réforme vous les
accentuez et même pire vous renoncez à
déjouer les pronostics ce qui est
pourtant au cœur du pacte républicain
alors on ne choisit pas toujours d'où
l'on vient ni le métier que l'on exerce
mais une chose est sûre l'école est
faite pour donner à tous ces élèves une
formation suffisamment qualifiante pour
avoir le choix de partir et de pouvoir
rebondir finalement cette réforme suit
la même logique que votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage à savoir le
travailleur va se soumettre au marché du
travail et son émancipation ça sera pour
plus tard ma question est assez simple
que comptez-vous faire pour sécuriser le
parcours de vie de notre jeunesse
en lycée professionnel je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues et la parole et
maintenant à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Cardon au
fond je crois que c'est la première fois
qu'un président de la République porte
aussi fort les valeurs de la voie
professionnelle et le lycée
professionnel au coeur de son engagement
de campagne et de politique publique au
fond tout doit être fait pour faire
réussir la jeunesse et effectivement
alors qu'un tiers des lycéens passe par
la voie professionnelle nous devons
accompagner l'évolution de la voie
professionnelle pour qu'elle mette en
réussite l'ensemble de ces jeunes vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur nous
avons un défi celui aussi de mettre en
place partout sur tous nos territoires
dans tous les lycées professionnels le
pacte républicain celui de la promesse
que nous devons leur faire qui est celui
de les accompagner bien sûr en tant que
citoyen pour qu'ils puissent grandir par
faire effectivement leur éducation et
être demain
citoyens éclairés qui s'engageront dans
une voie professionnelle et qui doit
aller préparer aussi à une insertion
professionnelle réussie c'est tout le
défi finalement de cette réforme
professionnelle c'est celle
d'accompagner les savoirs fondamentaux
que vous avez évoqués et monsieur le
Président de la République ainsi que
maniable la première ministre l'ont
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises nous
souhaitons préserver les savoirs
fondamentaux nous souhaitons accompagner
ces élèves souvent plus fragiles sur ses
savoirs fondamentaux qui sont essentiels
à l'air citoyenneté mais nous souhaitons
également leur donner toutes les cartes
pour qu'ils puissent s'insérer
professionnellement et réussir
l'insertion professionnelle qui
aujourd'hui je tiens à le rappeler ne
concerne qu'un élève sur deux diplômé
deux ans après l'obtention de leur
diplôme et or poursuit d'études cette ce
constat-là il n'est évidemment pas le
fait des enseignants qui sont évidemment
pris dans un système c'est de notre
responsabilité collective que
d'accompagner ce changement de système
pour que nous donnions toutes les cartes
aux enseignants pour qu'ils puissent
accompagner les élèves et les mettre en
situation de réussite effectivement
madame la ministre ben écoutez je ne
suis pas surpris de votre réponse vous
confortez même ce que je suis en train
de dire en tout cas tout ce que je vois
c'est que ce gouvernement est un
spécialiste des slogans notre école
faisons là ensemble notre lycée
professionnel faisons ensemble chiche
madame la ministre y aller chez moi en
tout cas il y a les faiseux et les 10
œufs les Français vous demandent tout
simplement d'être les feux et de
construire une vraie concertation pour
sauver le lycée professionnel et pas
l'inverse
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue philippe
Dominati pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a 4 ans
avec Peugeot et Renault la France
disposait de deux constructeurs
automobiles de dimension mondiale ayant
en commun un actionnaire l'État français
qui était un actionnaire d'influence
depuis l'un a trouvé la voie de la
croissance en acceptant d'être dilué
dans le groupe Fiat Chrysler groupe
italo-américain et l'autre est passée de
la première place mondiale à celle de
plus petit constructeur automobile
européen
hier le directeur général de Renault a
annoncé le troisième volet de son plan
pour cette entreprise ce plan qui
consiste à scinder en deux cette
entreprise et notamment avec de nouveaux
partenaires l'un chinois l'autre
saoudien
dans le même temps le directeur général
de Nissan en début de semaine dans la
presse économique revendiquée la
nécessité de rééquilibrer l'alliance
avec Renault
comme beaucoup de Français je
m'interroge et je m'étonne ce qui semble
être la passivité du gouvernement
français
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires dans la
mesure où
on ne comprend pas pourquoi 4 ans après
la crise suscitée par l'incarcération de
l'ancien directeur général de Renault
d'ailleurs sans preuve probante jusqu'à
ce jour le gouvernement accepte
éventuellement cette remise en cause je
voudrais savoir si il s'agit d'un
rééquilibrage volontaire ou si vous
allez accepter le démantèlement de cette
alliance
merci chers collègues la parole à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances
et merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Dominati je pense que vous avez
mis le doigt sur la réalité de
l'industrie automobile actuelle jusqu'à
quelques chiffres pour commencer
capitalisation boursière de Renault 6
milliards d'euros
capitalisation boursière de stellantis
44 milliards d'euros Ford 53 milliards
d'euros
Tesla
610 milliards d'euros
deuxième chiffre que je tiens à rappeler
Renault fait 60% de ses ventes c'est la
grande différence par rapport à ces
lentilles en Europe l'Europe a décidé
d'abandonner les véhicules thermiques
c'est pour ça que nous pensons que la
stratégie de lucabebo est la bonne
stratégie pour Renault la bonne
stratégie pour cette entreprise c'est
d'avoir une stratégie qui va lui
permettre de retrouver de l'espace
financier pour cela qu'elle sépare les
activités thermiques des activités
électriques et qu'elle a besoin d'un
partenaire je partenaire sur le chinois
Gilly qui je le rappelle est déjà
actionnaire majoritaire de Volvo
actionnaire de lotus et actionnaire de
Daimler en Allemagne c'est donc un
partenaire qui nous paraît un bon
partenaire
sous les activités électriques Renault
va pouvoir donc dégager des moyens
financiers plus importants pour investir
dans le moteur électrique investir dans
le véhicule électrique avec un projet de
1 million de véhicules électriques
réalisés dans le nord de la France
Renaud do va donc être un des fers de
l'ange de la réindustrialisation
automobile de notre pays il va
développer également des batteries
électriques pour que nous ayons
l'indépendance totale sur la chaîne il
va développer pour la première fois un
véhicule utilitaire léger électrique qui
va répondre à toutes les questions que
vous voyez souvent posées sur les
artisans les commerçants les BTP les
très petits entreprises qui ont besoin
de véhicules utilitaires électriques
légers ils seront produits à son
Douville en France par Renault nous
shootons donc cette stratégie qui doit
permettre la réindustrialisation
automobile sur la base du véhicule
électrique qui était lancée par le
cademeo et Renault s'agissant de
l'Alliance nous continuons à penser que
cette alliance entre Nissan et Renaud
est pertinente nous soutenons donc les
propos qui sont aujourd'hui sur la table
entre Renault et Nissan car les
synergies possibles qui remporteront
encore Renault
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Dominati
monsieur le ministre je suis pas très
convaincu de votre réponse parce que
vous correz Nissan ce qu'il y a de
gênant c'est tout sur l'électrique d'un
côté le président de la République nous
dit économiser mettez le chauffage à 19
degrés éteignez la Tour Eiffel faites un
certain nombre de choses la peine à
l'inclusion présidentielle terminée on
offre 7000 euros pour acheter une
voiture par exemple Nissan électrique
dont on ne sait pas véritablement
comment avec nos impôts on pourra faire
une Allemande continuer ce développement
avec cette politique dans les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris dans ma ville
monsieur de 2024 il y aura que des
voitures étrangères pour accueillir nos
autres merci
la parole est désormais à notre collègue
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour le groupe Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres l'économie et des finances
l'explosion du coût de l'énergie touche
de plein fouet et particuliers les
entreprises mais également les
collectivités territoriales garantes des
services publics du quotidien les
communions particuliers ont subi une
hausse ratosphérique des prix lors du
renouvellement de leur contrat de
fournisseurs d'énergie il en est le même
pour toutes les infrastructures
publiques qui leur sont liées à
commencer par les remontées mécaniques
par exemple pour mon département les
Hautes-Alpes pour l'avenir en aide ont
été mis en place ou promis une
succession de dispositifs budgétaires et
financiers tout d'abord cet été dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finances
rectificative a été instaurée à notre
initiative le Sénat un filet de sécurité
en faveur des collectivités il est qui
devait originalement concerné 22000
communes que nenni seule une infime
partie des collectivités en seront
finalement bénéficiaires par exemple
dans mon département 5 communes sur 162
ensuite nous avons eu l'introduction
d'un bouclier énergétique dans le projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 que nous
allons bientôt examiner ici au Sénat
enfin Madame borne première ministre a
récemment annoncé la mise en place d'un
amortisseur électricité nous attendons
là encore la parution d'un décret pour
savoir qui en bénéficiera précisément et
selon quelles conditions monsieur le
ministre tout ceci commence à ressembler
un véritable maquis nous avons du mal à
nous y retrouver alors imaginez
également les maires des petites
communes comment vont s'articuler ces
différents dispositifs toutes les
collectivités seront-elles concernées
par ces mesures de soutien et quand
toucheront-elles les premières aides
c'est essentiel pour le maintien des
services et qui m'empilent du quotidien
qu'elles assument
merci chers collègues la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre Christophe Béchu
finaliste de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires merci
monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs vous
permettraient de répondre
puisque la partie collectivité
territoriale a été plus intense dans
votre question que la partie économique
qui s'adressait à Bruno Le Maire d'abord
pour articuler très rapidement hier et
aujourd'hui il y a la situation de
l'année 2022 et il y a la situation de
l'année 2023 sur 2022 les choses sont
assez simples avec le bouclier qui a été
mis en place qui concerne toutes les
collectivités de moins de 10 salariés de
moins de 2 millions d'euros de budget et
pour celle là la règle 2022 sera la
règle 2023 toutes les entités de moins
de 10 salariés c'est le bouclier le
sujet c'est au-dessus pour l'année en
cours et le Sénat y a pris toute sa part
le filet de sécurité qui a été voté cet
été permettait de compenser le fait que
au-delà d'un certain niveau de dépenses
énergétiques il n'y avait pas de
dispositif spécifique pour les
collectivités
à l'heure où nous parlons vous savez que
les collectivités peuvent faire la
demande d'une avance et l'estimation sur
le nombre de communes par département
qui pourrait bénéficier du dispositif
vous avez l'air de le connaître chez
vous je ne le connais pas France entière
pour 2023 bouclier pour les moins de 10
amortisseurs pour celles qui sont à plus
de 10 salariés pour faire très simple
quand vous additionnez la moitié de la
facture qui est couverte par la reine et
la part qui est libre au-delà de 180
euros
du kilowatt-heure du mégawater nous nous
retrouvons dans un dispositif de soutien
qui prend la forme de 50% du niveau de
facture jusqu'à un plafond qui est situé
à 420 euros ça c'est le dispositif le
caractère pas immédiatement accessible
du calcul explique que le décret est
encore à la minute où nous parlons au
cours de rédaction et vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous allez dans
quelques jours pouvoir prendre le filet
de sécurité qui arrive de l'Assemblée
avec un aval qui a été donné par le
gouvernement pour un dispositif qui est
beaucoup plus puissant que celui qui a
été validé pour l'année 2000 22 puisque
c'est un milliard et demi d'euros que
nous envisageons de consacrer au soutien
des factures énergétiques de toutes les
collectivités locales qui se retrouvent
avec une diminution de leur capacité
d'autofinancement trop importante pour
qu'elle puisse supporter seul la facture
que le ministre
et nous ne doutons pas que le dialogue
permettra de simplifier le dispositif
Monsieur Arnaud
peut-être monsieur ministre parce que
vous n'avez pas pu terminer votre
intervention je n'ai pas tout compris
dans la réponse mais je tiens à vous
dire de manière très précise à qui
d'illustration dans mon département
lorsque vous regardez le dispositif
d'amortisseur électricité lorsque par
exemple les stations de sports d'hiver
des Hautes-Alpes se retrouvent à
utiliser ce dispositif elle se retrouve
avec une capacité à assumer les charges
énergétiques à hauteur de 20% de leur
chiffre d'affaires et donc ça signifie
que elles sont en situation de risque
vital à l'issue de la saison elles sont
en situation de faillite donc je crois
qu'il est nécessaire dans le dialogue
parlementaire de trouver des solutions
mais il faut trouver des solutions
opérationnelles et dès le premier
décembre monsieur Paul monsieur le
ministre je vous en conjure
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Claudine
Thomas pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre en août dernier
lors du vote de la loi de finances
rectificative pour 2022 le groupe les
républicains a fait adopter un
amendement il visait à mettre en place
les premiers crédits permettant de
lancer dès l'automne suivant le chantier
de la mise en oeuvre d'une carte Vitale
biométrique permettant de s'assurer
s'assurer de l'identité de son détenteur
la vie du gouvernement était à l'époque
un avis de sagesse et vous vous étiez
engagé à prévoir d'autres crédits
crédits dans le plfs plff pardon 2023
l'enjeu est important
un rapport conjoint de lié l'IGF et de
Ligas a estimé que le nombre de
titulaires d'une carte Vitale excédé de
plus de 7 millions le nombre de
personnes résidant en France
un rapport c'est un rapport sénatorial
quant à lui l'évaluait en 2019 entre
deux et plus de 5 millions et la
directrice de la sécurité sociale en
2020 reconnaissait lors d'une audition
Parlement un surnom de 2,16 millions de
cartes vitales quant au montant de la
fraude sociale il aussi irait entre 14
et 45 milliards d'euros par an la fraude
à la carte Vitale ayant toute sa part
dans cette dérive
madame ce sujet de la fraude sociale
mériterait que le gouvernement sans
saisisse vraiment
or que constate-t-on non seulement le
gouvernement n'a rien fait pour aller
dans ce sens mais pire encore aucun
crédit n'est inscrit pour cette action
au PLFSS 2023
décidément votre gouvernement a bien du
mal à écouter le Parlement apprendre le
chemin de la réforme et à se donner les
moyens et d'économiser l'argent public
j'aurais donc trois questions
ne pensez-vous pas madame la Première
ministre que la lutte contre la fraude
sociale devrait être une priorité et que
tous les moyens pour y contribuer de
votre être mise en oeuvre pourquoi
avez-vous refusé d'inscrire pour 2023
des crédits et donc d'engager enfin le
programme de création des cartes vitales
biométriques et pour finir au-delà de
votre réticence à agir se poser une
question plus large que ne pensez-vous
pas que dans une démocratie les
décisions du
Parlement pardon c'est à dire ce que
prévoit la loi doit être respecté par le
gouvernement
la parole pour répondre est à la manière
le Bodo minis délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
qui correspondent davantage aux nouveaux
usages ainsi qu'aux attentes des
professionnels de santé eux-mêmes une
phase d'expérimentation a été entamée en
2019 auprès d'assuré et des
professionnels de santé la carte vitale
des matérialisée est en cours dans huit
départements jusqu'à l'année jusqu'à la
fin de l'année auprès des assurés
volontaires en parallèle de cette étude
sur la carte Vitale biométrique le
gouvernement entend aller au terme de
cette expérimentation qui d'ailleurs
pour sécuriser l'identification de la
personne contient de la biométrie cette
carte vitale des matérialisée pourrait
être généralisée à partir de 2023 en
fonction de résultat de l'évaluation et
des exigences de simplification
auxquelles nous sommes très attachés je
vous remercie
bien merci Madame la Ministre la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue Marie
Harley Carlotti pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues depuis 54
jours le sang coule en Iran et c'est
d'abord le sang des femmes en février 79
avant même l'instauration de la
République islamique d'Iran l'ayatollah
romini considérait déjà que la liberté
de la femme était un principal obstacle
à son projet politique et depuis
l'élection de l'ultra conservateur Haïti
la situation c'est encore dégradée
depuis 54 jours depuis la mort de Massa
Amini les manifestations se multiplient
et la répression est de plus en plus
brutale au fur et à mesure que le
pouvoir se sent en danger une répression
sans précédent s'en bat sur le peuple
iranien la politique ouvre la police
ouvre le feu sur les manifestants il y a
plus de 300 morts 14000 arrestations
comme ces deux journalistes qui sont
aujourd'hui en prison parce qu'elles ont
dénoncé le crime commis par la police
des mœurs toutes celles qui brûlent leur
voile qui arragent leur carcans qui se
coupe les cheveux risque aujourd'hui la
peine de mort
l'intégralité des droits humains et
pourtant et pourtant depuis mai 2021 la
République islamique d'Iran est membre
de la Commission de la condition des
femmes des Nations Unies c'est
surréaliste en niant le droit des femmes
et en menant une répression féroce
contre son peuple l'Iran vous en
conviendrez à démontrer qu'il n'avait
pas sa place au sein d'une commission
qui promeut le droit des femmes et
d'égalité des sexes les premiers à
réagir ont été les Canadiens puis ce
furent les États-Unis qui lancent
désormais une initiative pour provoquer
le départ de l'Iran de cet instance que
dit la France que dit la France monsieur
le ministre vous allez aller vous exiger
l'exclusion de l'Iran de la Commission
des Droits des Femmes de l'ONU le régime
des mots là n'a rien à y faire
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier belge
qui ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Carlotti d'abord je voudrais
excuser l'absence de la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine Colonna oui le
mouvement de protestation des iraniennes
et des Iraniens se poursuit alors que le
26 octobre a marqué le 40e jour suivant
le décès de Massa Amini il y a un moment
essentiel du
cyclable de deuil musulman child
plusieurs cérémonies de deuil pour
d'autres protestataires décédés au début
du mouvement ont été organisés ces
derniers jours c'est très nombreux et
triste anniversaire suicide et
rassemblements qui continuent de faire
résonner qui a le cri femme vit liberté
face au revendications légitime de la
jeunesse iranienne les autorités
maintiennent leur répression violente et
oui le bilan aujourd'hui est de plus de
300 morts
comme vous le savez nous avons réagi
fermement à cette brutalité notamment à
travers un premier paquet de sanctions
européennes adopter le 17 octobre visant
les responsables de la répression nous
travaillons actuellement avec nos
partenaires européens à un second paquet
de sanctions visant d'autres
responsables il ne doit y avoir et il y
aura aucune impunité à aucun niveau en
fin de semaine dernière nous avons
également échangé avec nos partenaires
du G7 au sein de l'évolution de la
situation en Iran nous partageons les
mêmes préoccupations très fortes quant à
la réponse brutale des autorités
iraniennes aux aspirations légitimes de
sa population nous sommes donc tous au
clair si la répression se poursuit c'est
aussi les sanctions qui se poursuivront
et la France agira à tous les niveaux y
compris au niveau de l'organisation des
Nations Unies si nécessaire
madame Carlotti
merci monsieur le ministre je regrette
cette réponse timide
certes nous certes des sanctions ont été
prises par la France et par l'Union
européenne mais elles sont bien timides
aujourd'hui et pendant ce temps-là le
régime continue à tuer aujourd'hui la
situation s'est aggravée il y a urgence
et c'est plus le moment de la simple
compassion ça ne suffit pas nous
attendons de la France qu'elle soit plus
audible pour dénoncer la répression et
pour défendre ceux qui se battent pour
leur liberté alors faisons les sortir de
la Commission
[Applaudissements]
bien merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Jérôme
Bacher pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire mise de
l'économie monsieur le ministre nous
connaissons depuis longtemps et nous
partageons à une époque la conviction
commune qu'il fallait lutter contre les
déficits or depuis 5 ans et demi que
vous êtes ministre de l'Économie vous
serez le ministre du record historique
du déficit public du déficit budgétaire
mais aussi et voilà l'exploit du déficit
commercial
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues nous
pouvons penser que en fin d'année nous
serons à 200 milliards de déficit
commercial 150 milliards sur trois
trimestres et il s'aggravent de
trimestre entre trimestre alors Monsieur
le Ministre comment analysez-vous votre
échec et qu'elle à partir de cette bonne
analyse quelle piste avez-vous pour
redresser la barre
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
[Applaudissements]
le sénateur bachel si c'est un échec
c'est un échec collectif puisque depuis
2000 la balance commerciale n'a jamais
été excédentaire dans notre pays donc je
suggère je vous suggère de chercher
plutôt ensemble des solutions plutôt que
d'accalabry tous les bancs de cette
assemblée gauche et droite confondues la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui l'excédent
commercial dont j'ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises que nous devions en
faire une des grandes batailles
économiques de la prochaine décennie
c'est d'abord dû à l'augmentation de la
facture énergétique et à notre
dépendance énergétique sur les 16
milliards d'euros de déficits
commerciales supplémentaires que nous
venons d'enregistrer les deux tiers sont
liés à la facture énergétique je cherche
pas je ne cherche pas des subterfuges je
dis qu'elles sont les réalités
aujourd'hui des chiffres la deuxième
raison vous la connaissez aussi bien que
moi je connais votre attachement à ce
sujet
cela désindustrialisation massive de la
France depuis trois décennies il n'y
aura pas d'excédents de la balance
commerciale française sans
réindustrialisation massive rapide
volontariste notre pays quelle est la
seule majorité qui depuis 20 ans
a recréé des emplois industriels dans
notre pays c'est la nôtre
quelle est la seule majorité qui peut
dire que nous avons ouvert plus d'usines
l'année dernière que nous en avons fermé
c'est la nôtre
quelle est la seule majorité qui est le
courage de baisser les impôts de
production de 10 milliards d'euros et
qui va à nouveau les baisser pour les
années qui viennent c'est la nôtre donc
si vous voulez réduire la déficit de la
balance commerciale extérieure votez
avec nous la nouvelle baisse des impôts
de production soutenez l'industrie
soutenez leur indiscréalisation du pays
et là nous aurons enfin une balance
commerciale extérieure positive
monsieur Bacher alors Monsieur le
Ministre tout à l'heure vous allez
raconter une histoire là vous ne
raconter des histoires
car nous venons exactement de vous
expliquer ce qu'il fallait faire écoutez
bien la suite des questions du groupe
les républicains tout à l'heure on vous
a expliqué ce que c'était pour le
déficit public avec Priscille Lavarde
sur la réindustrialisation de notre
industrie de santé sur la
réindustrialisation de notre automobile
la semaine dernière où il y a 15 jours
plus exactement le rendu plomb vous
rappelait sur l'agriculture oui nous
vous faisons des propositions mais vous
les entendez pas par dogme nous
proposons d'abord des normes et après on
dit à notre industrie vous n'avez plus
qu'à vous adapter et bien non on donne
des Caps clairs monsieur le ministre on
indique ce qu'on veut faire au pays vous
nous dites faut que ça soit la prochaine
décennie mais vous avez raté la décennie
dernière vous avez raté la décennie
dernière ce pays n'est aujourd'hui pas
souverain et en ce jour anniversaire de
la mort du général la souveraineté
aurait méritée d'être vraiment mis à
l'honneur vous l'avez la souveraineté
dans les titres vous ne l'avez pas dans
les faits
[Applaudissements]
la parole la parole est maintenant à
d'autres collègues Claude Kern pour le
groupe Union centriste merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
l'installation illicite des gens du
voyage est une problématique qui n'est
pas nouvelle loin de là cela fait 20 ans
qu'elle revient régulièrement sur le
tapis sans toutefois constater de
changement effectifs la loi Besson n'est
ni efficace ni appliquée et des
situations difficiles en découle pour
leur pour nos communes j'ai encore eu
connaissance de plusieurs cas en Alsace
et je ne et je sais que mes collègues
élus dans d'autres départements sont
confrontés aux mêmes problématiques
certes certaines intercommunalités
encore des difficultés pour développer
des aires du grand passage nécessaire au
respect de la loi mais qu'en est-il des
territoires qui sont en conformité avec
le schéma départemental et qui subissent
régulièrement des installations
illicites ces communautés refusant de
s'installer sur les airs dédié les élus
se retrouvent alors démunies face à des
communautés qui ont une parfaite
connaissance des procédures leur
permettant de faire échec un arrêté
préfectoral de mise en demeure en
saisissant immédiatement le juge
administratif d'un référé suspensif un
trou dans la raquette qui leur permet de
prolonger leur présence sur le site
qu'ils ont investi en toute illégalité
c'est cette suspension qui pose problème
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
faire respecter la loi sans pour autant
oublier la question de l'après qui est
tout aussi importante car trop souvent
les terrains occupés sont laissés dans
un mauvais état avec des dégâts
conséquents monsieur le ministre dans
quel débat délai allez-vous déposer un
projet de loi qui met définitivement un
terme à ces installations illicites et
protège les élus
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les statuts monsieur le
sénateur Kern comme vous je constate que
les lois Besson 1 et B sont deux sont
difficilement applicables et en effet je
crois que l'autorité républicaine est
plusieurs fois bafoué les accueils mis
en place par les élus locaux souvent
ravagés et évidemment pour nos citoyens
des décisions administratives ou
d'édition de justice peut compréhensible
et qu'à ce titre je veux évidemment
faire le constat avec vous que nous
devons améliorer le texte de loi vous
m'accorderez que les préfets de la
République appliquent la loi telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui rédigée faut-il
que ce soit une proposition de loi après
tout la Haute Assemblée comme
l'Assemblée nationale pourrait tout à
fait le proposer faut-il que ce soit un
texte du Gouvernement peut-être un texte
ensemble si vous le permettez monsieur
le sénateur pour pouvoir à la fois
évidemment accueillir les gens du voyage
qui ont évidemment le droit de vivre
comme il le souhaite sur le territoire
de la République évidemment au
conformité
vous savez que la bien-séance
républicaine et le respect évidemment
des choses publiques ainsi que la
propriété privée de nos concitoyens pour
avoir été maire d'une commune qui
n'avait pas d'un accueil des gens du
voyage je sais à quel point il est
difficile pour une mairie de pouvoir la
mettre en place mais je veux rappeler
d'abord que la loi Besson 2 doit
répondre pour l'ensemble des élus de la
République au schéma départementaux et
je ne peux malheureusement que constater
qu'à certains nombre de conseils
départementaux n'ont pas mis en place en
place encore leur schéma départemental
où on passe demander la révision de
celui-ci deuxièmement la question qui se
pose monsieur le sénateur c'est lorsque
les personnes s'installent sur des
terrains privés ou sur un terrain public
ou une partie d'un terrain public ou le
détenteur de la propriété ne souhaite
pas déposer plainte soit pour des
raisons volontaires soit parce qu'on ne
connaît pas le propriétaire de ce
terrain voilà notamment avide juridique
auquel il faudra tous répondre pour que
les préfets puissent appliquer la force
publique lorsqu'ils ont soit en flag
soit par décision de justice les moyens
de le faire et ils le font à chaque fois
que vous me saisissez
merci Monsieur Kern
merci monsieur le ministre je nous
prenons note de votre proposition et
nous sommes naturellement prêt à
travailler avec vous pour améliorer ces
situations mais comprenez que
aujourd'hui c'est si ces installations
illicites ne peuvent plus perdus
perdurer et d'autant plus qu'elles ont
souvent lieu à proximité d'habitation
privée un dernier mot concernant
peut-être également l'installation
illégale de cirque qui s'installe malgré
l'interdiction formelle qui leur est
notifié préalablement sur ce point
également les élus locaux sont en
attente d'une réponse rapide et
efficiente merci merci chers collègues
nous en avons terminé pour aujourd'hui
je vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
auront lieu le mercredi 16 novembre 2022
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30
pour la suite du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Cénac que
vous avez suivi en direct et en
intégralité depuis 15h sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat parmi les moments forts
cette semaine on retient ce bras de fer
sur le budget des collectivités locales
la droite sénatoriale à vivement
critiqué les choix budgétaires du
gouvernement et l'instauration des
contrats dit de confiance des contrats
imprévus dans le budget 2023 et qui
limite la hausse des budgets des
différentes strates des collectivités
locales c'est vu comme un retour des
fameux contrats de Cahors mis en place
entre 2018 et 2020 et qui avait été vécu
comme une forme de recentralisation par
les collectivités locales écoutez la
question de la sénatrice LR Christine
Lavarde
comment pouvez-vous
oser redéposer par l'intermédiaire d'un
49-3 une disposition qui a été rejetée
par les deux assemblées une première
fois à l'Assemblée nationale une
deuxième fois au Sénat et cette
disposition d'ailleurs a été déposée en
4 minutes car elle ne figurerait pas
dans les amendements retenus dans la
première version du texte et on l'a vu
arriver dans le texte consolidé envoyé
le jeudi matin aux assemblées je parle
là des contrats de confiance au contrat
de Cahors
dit pendant de longues secondes par la
droite un sénatoriale mais par d'autres
sénateurs aussi car on voit que cette
question des budgets des collectivités
locales elle inquiète beaucoup de
sénateurs et on l'entend que ce soit
autant sur la méthode dans le 49-3 que
sur le fond de la mesure proposée
écoutez la réponse de Christophe Béchu
qui dispose du portefeuille de la
cohésion des territoires
il a été décidé dans le cadre du PLF de
réintroduire les articles dont nous
avions besoin pour crédibiliser cette
trajectoire des finances publiques et
très concrètement c'est une façon aussi
de reprovoquer le dialogue on peut pas
écarter d'un revers de main
j'ose espérer
que ça n'est pas la nature de la
relation que vous aurez quand on va
entrer dans le détail de ces articles le
gouvernement est prêt sur ce sujet à
discuter mais il considère que la voix
d'un compromis à la fois sur les
finances des collectivités sur les
finances de l'état nécessite précisément
un travail de co-construction et le
balayer d'un revers de main ne peut pas
être une attitude responsable voilà la
réponse de Christophe Béchu qui n'a pas
convaincu les sénateurs de tout bord ici
au Sénat mais on le voit à cette
question et qui est préoccupe beaucoup
un dessinateur puisqu'il y a eu pas
moins Tam de trois questions au
Gouvernement aujourd'hui sur ce sujet du
budget des collectivités locales on le
sait aussi à un an des élections
sénatoriales et à deux semaines du 104e
congrès de l'AMF les maires de France
qui se tiendra à Paris du 22 24 novembre
merci merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes
ces explications donc voilà l'un des
temps forts de cette séance qui était
donc cons aux collectivités on l'a
entendu avec cette interpellation de
Christine lavardde qui a donc ouvert la
séance de questions au Gouvernement
notez que lors de cette séance il y a
également eu plusieurs questions
consacrées au transport et on va
d'ailleurs rejoindre tout de suite la
salle des conférences où se trouve
alexandre Poussin avec Clément bon le
ministre délégué chargé des transports
c'est à VOUS Alexandre effectivement tu
as beaucoup de questions sur les
transports et notamment sur la
dégradation du service ferroviaire
depuis des semaines avec beaucoup de
trains annulés alors dans les hauts de
France mais aussi dans d'autres régions
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce qui se
passe avec notre service ferroviaire
tout d'abord je veux avoir un mot pour
les gens qui galèrent depuis la rentrée
dans un certain nombre de régions il
faut quand même juste la situation n'est
pas du tout la même partout en France il
y a deux régions aujourd'hui qui vivent
des difficultés très fortes et très
particulières les hauts de France je me
suis rendu lundi à Lille j'ai échange
avec le président de région vous avez
Bertrand hier avec le président de la
SNCF monsieur pharadou il y a une
pénurie de conducteurs et donc j'ai
demandé qu'il y a un plan tout à fait
exceptionnel pour les hauts de France
qui soit mis en place inédit avec des
gratuitement qui sont le plus accélérés
possible pour qu'on résolve ces
difficultés de pénurie et donc de galère
du quotidien pour beaucoup de gens en
Île-de-France on a une situation qui est
difficile aussi il y a un plan qui a été
mis en place d'ores et déjà par la RATP
ça prend un peu de temps pour recruter
aussi massivement on travaille avec la
région qui a l'organisation la
responsabilité de l'organisation des
transports pour que cela s'améliore le
plus vite possible il faut mettre la
pression sur tout le monde pour qu'on y
arrive vous mettez la pression est-ce
que le gouvernement accompagne avec des
moyens pour briser ses recrute bien sûr
nous avons un budget qui est en cours de
discussion il y a un effort inédit pour
les transports publics deux choses
là-dessus est-ce qu'on peut aller plus
loin oui je le pense il y a un travail
parlementaire qui est en cours pour
avoir une programmation sur plusieurs
années il y a ces mesures d'urgence qui
doivent répondre aux situations les plus
difficiles aujourd'hui et puis on doit
encore sans doute notre réseau c'est ce
qui relève de l'État dans nos lignes la
grande vitesse dans les lignes
d'équilibre du territoire investir
encore plus dans les années qui viennent
alors demain il y aura un jeudi noir
dans les transports parisiens mais aussi
dans d'autres villes qu'est-ce que vous
dites assez grévistes notamment assez
conducteur qui estime qu'il doit avoir
des hausses de salaire et une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail je respecte à la fois le droit
constit tunnel de grève bien sûr les
discussions et les préoccupations
légitimes sur le pouvoir d'achat il y a
eu parce que le dialogue fonctionne le
dialogue social fonctionne à nos grandes
entreprises de transport je veux le
saluer il y a eu déjà des négociations à
la RATP ouais SNCF par exemple avec des
augmentations salariales importantes ces
derniers mois donc je n'ai pas jugé le
reste simplement je pense surtout à ceux
qui vont galérer demain il y a dans la
dans la transport parisiens pardon pour
la RATP des difficultés extrêmement
importantes pour la SNCF c'est
heureusement moins important mais sur
certaines lignes de TER et chacun doit
se renseigner aujourd'hui des prévisions
sont désormais publiques pour
s'organiser le mieux possible et
conscience que c'est une journée en plus
qui est très difficile nous faisons le
tout aussi là pour que le dialogue je
reprenne ses droits et qu'il n'y ait pas
une grève qui se poursuive et je crois
que ce ne sera pas le cas alors
justement à propos des transports
parisiens et de la RATP de la région
autonome des transports parisiens et
bien son nouveau président a été nommé
sa nomination était validée par le
Parlement aujourd'hui ce sera Jean
Castex l'ancien Premier ministre
certains disent que c'est d'abord un
petit peu un recazage d'un ancien membre
du gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce
que vous dites ça mais là complètement
Jean Castex et engagé sur les transports
de longue date il a été sans doute comme
aucun Premier ministre ces dernières
années avec des efforts budgétaires
justement très importants sur les
petites lignes sur les transports du
quotidien un ancien Premier ministre qui
prend la tête d'une entreprise publique
sur le contrôle du Parlement qui a voté
favorablement au-delà des clivages
politiques assemblés nationales comme
Sénat je crois que c'est une preuve
d'engagement pour le service public
franchement il y a des requinsages si je
puis dire qui serait si ça l'était plus
confortable plus comme l'a dit Jean
Castex destinécure que la prendre la
tête de RATP dans la situation qui est
celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui et je
pense que c'est l'homme de la situation
il faut de la force il faut de
l'engagement pour la RATP notre service
public de transport alors en tout cas du
fait de son ancienne fonction de Premier
ministre et bien la Haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique a mis
certaines contraintes notamment dans sa
communication avec le gouvernement
concrètement est-ce que Jean Castex
pourra vous parler oui il doit être très
clair là-dessus il pourrait y avoir des
échanges des rendez-vous de travail
évidemment il y a des précautions très
spécifiques sur certains sujets
l'ouverture à la concurrence par exemple
parce que le gouvernement précédent a eu
à en connaître et c'est normal sur ce
sujet ne pourra pas vous parler alors
sur ce sujet il aura des discussions
avec la région puisque c'est la région
Île-de-France qui est en charge pour les
transports franciliens de l'organisation
de cette ouverture à concurrence donc
aucun problème et dès les premières
heures les premiers jours je crois les
premières heures de la nomination de
Lancaster nous aurons les échanges et il
y a un conseil administration de
l'entreprise le 14 novembre ensuite il
faut une nomination en conseil des
ministres donc c'est aujourd'hui une
affaire de jour et je me réjouis de ce
vol positif qui Parlement et de
l'arrivée imminente Jean Castex à la
tête de ce grand service public merci
beaucoup merci Clément bonne d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci merci
beaucoup Alexandre effectivement la
nomination de Jean Castex qui a été
validé aujourd'hui par le Parlement
après son audition au Sénat hier à
l'Assemblée aujourd'hui on va commencer
par parler de ça avec mes invités pour
se débrief avec Thomaso sub bonjour vous
êtes sénateur écologiste du Rhône à côté
de vous Jérôme Bachar bonjour sénateur
LR de l'Oise et face à vous Martin
lévrier bonjour sénateur renaissance des
Yvelines et vice-président de la
Commission des affaires vous pencher
beaucoup sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale en ce moment notamment mais
d'abord un mot sur et bien cette
nomination celle de Jean Castex à la
tête de la RATP il a consacré une partie
de son audition hier au fait de dire
qu'il allait accorder beaucoup
d'importance au dialogue social dans
cette entreprise où ça va assez mal
actuellement et où donc il y a une
journée noire prévue demain Thomas
dessus est-ce que c'est pour vous la
bonne personne au bon endroit
ça donne une image assez désastreuse en
réalité de du pouvoir et de la politique
avec le recazage des copains en
permanence on a eu manuel vargon il y a
quelques semaines maintenant on a
Jean-Castet avec son attention
[Musique]
Castaner en réalité c'est un problème
parce que ça jette un peu un voile de
suspicion sur les compétences réelles
des personnes ou l'endroit où ils sont
nommés
ça a été soulevé par la Haute Autorité
de la transparence de la vie publique où
il aura des contraintes pour exercer ce
mandat de à la RATP donc forcément ça
pose un problème quand même ça pose un
problème Martin lévrier qu'est-ce que
vous répondez écoutez d'abord on parle
de recazage je suis un peu surpris pour
l'instant la RATP n'est pas dans une
forme éblouissante les confrontés à
certains nombre de problèmes donc c'est
pas vraiment un requinage c'est un c'est
un poste
pour tout le monde rêve je pense pour
passer des jours tranquilles ça c'est
certain et moi je vois en jean Castan en
Jean Castex un homme de
qui a su relever le défi de la crise que
nous avons covid que nous avons subi où
il a pris les rênes en tant que Premier
ministre et il a organisé tout le
système qui nous a permis de sortir de
cette crise dans les meilleures
conditions possibles c'est un homme de
vrais défis c'est un homme de compétence
que nous avons tous remarqué ça donne de
terrain c'est un homme de territoire et
moi je pense que pour répondre aux défis
de la RATP il faut un homme de
conviction un homme de grande solidité
qui sait parler aux gens et je crois que
Jean Castel effectivement
j'allais dire une phrase anglaise je ne
la dirais pas l'homme l'homme qu'il faut
l'homme de la situation
il est compétent mais il est empêché il
est compétent personne ne peut dire le
contraire il a exercé les plus grandes
fonctions dans ce pays
mais en revanche il est totalement
empêché je suis désolé
secrétaire d'État j'encaisse j'ai pas de
problème ah si et puis le ministre du
budget car c'est bizarre que les bambous
ne doit pas bien connaître le budget de
la France et donc une partie des mesures
qui concerne la RATP et Île de France
mobilité qui sont dans les lois de
finances on en a débattu souvent y
compris d'ailleurs dans les périodes
électorales lorsque Laurent Saint-Martin
avait des ambitions pour conquérir la
région Île-de-France où il avait un peu
empêché un certain nombre de subventions
à l'époque pour Île-de-France habitait
donc il est empêché donc c'est sans
doute un homme de dialogue il est
compétent mais il est empêché
aujourd'hui moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que on ne peut pas dire la Haute
Autorité on l'a bien instauré en début
de quinquennat de François de
Emmanuel Macron pardon d'Emmanuel Macron
et après on s'assoit parce qu'en fait
c'est ça on s'assoit sur ce que vient de
dire la Haute autorité et on décrédibise
la Haute autorité dans ce qu'elle
raconte jusque l'autre l'idée à valider
malgré tout avec des raisins mais la
validé donc mais les réserves ne sont
invisiables et quand vous faites cela et
bien vous n'êtes pas insoupçonnable et
ça c'est dommage
nos propres ou au moins un voile de
suspicion permanent sur le travail de
Jean c'est dommage parce qu'il a besoin
de travailler en confiance on a on parle
de transport il y a aussi plusieurs
questions sur l'état des du train en
France Thomas dessus il y a tout un
sujet qui se pose aujourd'hui à la fois
sur le prix du transport à la question
du bouclier tarifaire parce que bien sûr
la SNCF va devoir faire face à
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie
alors est-ce que ça va se répercuter sur
les billets et puis il y a un autre
sujet c'est bien celui du déblocage de
c'est bon pour la SNCF qui avait été
adoptée notamment à l'Assemblée mais
refusé par le gouvernement aujourd'hui
il faut plus d'argent pour le train oui
alors c'est pas moi qui vais le dire
c'est Jean-Pierre farandoux qui dit
qu'il faut investir 100 milliards sur
les 15 prochaines années pour avoir un
réseau à la hauteur à la fois des trains
du quotidien qui sont actuellement dans
un état de qualité service assez
déplorable mais aussi pour augmenter la
part de Fred augmenter le les transports
RER dans les grandes métropoles il y a
quelque chose il y a beaucoup d'argent
public à mettre il y a à l'Assemblée
avait décidé d'un moment de 4 milliards
ce qui est déjà insuffisant mais qui
quand même faisait déjà un effort
important et le gouvernement comme sur
beaucoup de d'autres sujets à balayer
cet amendement adopté par le par
l'assemblée par le 49-3 voilà on nous
dit il faut tout miser sur le train mais
on nous donne pas les financements
nécessaires je me rappelle je me
rappelle qu'il y avait donc le déblocage
de 3 milliards d'euros qui avait été
adoptés à l'Assemblée nationale par les
oppositions et que le gouvernement s'y
opposé Martin lévrier oui c'est opposé
mais ça n'empêche pas il y a énormément
d'investissements qui sont en cours et
qui se font en particulier sur des
lignes qui ont été totalement
abandonnées depuis 30 ans parce que le
problème le problème que nous avons
aujourd'hui sur la SNCF sur les
transports de façon générale c'est une
forme d'abandon de l'état de tous ces
prérogatifs depuis 30 ans qui a fait
qu'il n'y avait plus d'investissement
qui sauf sur les grandes lignes TGV
pendant 20 ans à peu près et qu'on doit
rattraper tout ça donc le choix du
gouvernement ça a été de rattraper le
retard je vous rappelle toutes les lois
qui ont été faites de 2019 de mémoire à
2022 qui ont essayé de rattraper avec
des investissements colossaux j'ai pu
les montants en tête mais 18 merci
lentement que je sais que mon collègue
donnera les montants parce qu'il les
connaît mieux que moi même s'il ne lui
rendent pas service parce qu'ils sont
très bons pour la SNCF mais ce retard à
rattrapé il est surtout sur les petites
lignes et toutes ces lignes qui ont été
abandonnées pour le transport du
quotidien
euh Jérôme bachel donc euh depuis plus
de 20 ans je prends le train et la
création elle est formidable dans les
hauts de France c'est simple l'année
dernière c'est plus de 11000 trains
supprimés 11000 train du quotidien
supprimé et aujourd'hui le nouveau plan
qu'on prévoit la SNCF c'est 140 - par
euh
pardon 1140 trains par mois donc en
vérité ils veulent supprimer dans déjà
pour l'an prochain autant de tranquille
ils ont supprimé l'année dernière on
vous imaginez bien que ce n'est pas le
langage sur le train pour vous parce que
c'est nécessaire
des chemins de fer ceci national on nous
dit il y a pas assez de chauffeur en
région Hauts-de-France mais c'est une
société nationale à ce moment-là ou chez
une société nationale et donc on déplace
des chauffeurs de train c'est tout les
conducteurs alors ce sujet bien sûr du
transport du train et d'autant plus
important qu'aujourd'hui et bien nous
sommes en pleine COP 27 et que le train
c'est bien sûr dans des modes de
transport les plus écologiques et sur ce
sujet on va alexandre Poussin qui se
trouve avec le président du groupe
écologiste c'est Guillaume Gontard
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé des
annonces du président de la République
en début de semaine notamment autour de
la COP 27 pour protéger nos fonds marins
et des pays pauvres à faire leur
transition énergétique et puis également
des carbonées notre industrie est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron est volontariste en
terme d'écologie sur la scène
internationale on est des annonces
intéressantes parce que sur les fonds le
fond marin on le demandait et on
l'attendait donc je dirais enfin
heureusement et heureusement qu'on aille
dans cette direction et on a besoin
d'aller vite et d'avoir des actions donc
voilà faut pas que des paroles
maintenant il faut des actions sur la
décarbonation et sur la question de la
réalisation pareil moi j'attends des
actions on a eu un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables dans lequel il y
avait pas de voler justement sur la
question de l'industrie alors que on va
produire des panneaux enfin on va devoir
produire des panneaux photovoltaïques
énormément sur 10 20 ans et on est
toujours à la traîne et on abandonne des
entreprises j'en ai une sur mon
territoire qui n'attend que ça d'avoir
des investissements pour pouvoir réduire
des panneaux français de A à Z sachant
qu'on est aussi producteur de silicium
donc on peut tout faire dans notre pays
et pour l'instant ce n'est pas ce qui se
fait et les annonces de Madame panyruche
pendant le texte sur les énergies
renouvelables et pas très rassurant
c'est à dire que toujours on va recréer
quelque chose de nouveau sans utiliser
l'expérience sans utiliser les
compétences qui sont sur nos territoires
alors qu'on en a réellement besoin et
que c'est ça aussi cette transition
écologique en lien et ancré sur nos
territoires alors on a des sites
industriels qui émettent beaucoup de gaz
à effet de serre Emmanuel Macron a lancé
un accompagnement de 10 milliards
d'euros pour verdir nos 50 sites
industriels les plus polluants ça ça va
dans le bon sens bah oui ça va gérer ça
va dans le bon sens si ça se met
réellement en place et si on a des
actions très ciblées je redonne encore
un exemple sur mon territoire ou le
territoire d'à côté la Savoie on produit
on produisait du silicium et le silicium
c'est très gourmand en énergie on a des
électrodes et ben on a arrêté une
industrie une entreprise qui bénéficie
des droits d'électricité pour en ouvrir
d'autres en Europe avec une énergie
carbonée donc là effectivement je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut peut-être
se mettre en accord avec avec les
paroles avec ce qu'on dit et surtout
aller beaucoup plus vite parce que on a
ce besoin là et surtout je dirais on a
des perspectives notamment sur la
question de l'énergie sur la question du
solaire et du photovoltaïque mais aussi
dans d'autres domaines donc ce que vous
dites c'est qu'il y a un petit peu en
écart entre les paroles d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la scène international et ses
actes concrets sur la scène nationale
bah en tout cas c'est pas forcément ce
qu'on constate quand on va rencontrer
les entreprises quand on va voir ce qui
se passe moi sur mon territoire le
paracétamol alors je le salue on a une
unité de fabrication de paresse étamol
très bien mais c'est une usine qui en
2009 on a totalement rasé totalement
fermé parce qu'on en a pas besoin donc
on voit bien qu'il faut qu'on voit
totalement notre notre logiciel que la
question je dirais à la fois
concurrentielle de compétitivité il faut
la regarder au loin justement de
l'impact de l'impact carbone de l'impact
environnemental et on doit revoir toute
ma notre manière de faire et j'ai
l'impression que Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement ont encore du mal à changer
ce logiciel et cette manière de voir les
choses il l'avenir de votre industrie
qui est auto coeur de notre transition
écologique merci beaucoup Guillaume
gantard d'être venu sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre il
y a eu cette séance de questions
gouvernement qui se déroule donc pendant
la COP 27 la COP qui a commencé ce
week-end avec et bien des propos forts
notamment du Secrétaire général de l'ONU
qui a dit l'humanité doit choisir entre
solidarité et suicide collectif est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ces propos
Martin lévrier avec leurs dimensions à
l'armiste est-ce que c'est utile de
s'exprimer de cette façon là en cette
période où bien sûr le réchauffement
climatique est un problème majeur
j'allais dire malheureusement rien de
nouveau souvenez-vous du président
Chirac la maison brûle me regardant
ailleurs et c'est pas nouveau donc moi
je dis maintenant attention et je
rejoins un peu ce que dit le président
gronder tout à l'heure et je reprends
son exemple sur l'usine de paracétamol
c'est pas l'écologie mais ça revient au
même son industrialisation on ferme une
usine en 2009 on la réouvre aujourd'hui
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'on s'est
trompé qu'on a cru que la mondialisation
serait un vrai bonheur pour tout le
monde et aujourd'hui on est confronté à
un double problème ce problème du climat
qui est colossal que l'on connaît depuis
maintenant j'allais dire 30 ans sans
discussion on pouvait en discuter avant
des grandes envies politiques donc on
parlait maintenant il est temps d'agir
et il est temps d'agir tous ensemble et
là et là je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
plus le temps de des shikayas et des
discussions de de petites semaines sur
est-ce que c'était bien de faire comme
ça avant ou pas bien est-ce que est-ce
que l'énergie nucléaire est bien ou pas
bien on en connaît les résultats mais on
sait aussi et c'est peut-être la plus
grande difficulté qu'on a c'est que
c'est un problème mondial où tout le
monde doit intervenir et la France a
beau être meneur parce que on peut dire
ce qu'on veut la France est un des pays
les plus en avance ou les moins ou les
plus avancés en tout cas sur ce combat
pour pour essayer de prévoir les climat
mais seul on ne peut rien faire ou pas
grand chose et ce sujet là il est
mondial c'est ce qu'a dit un peu le
Président il a quand même dit un certain
nombre de choses de présidents Macron a
dit un certain nombre de choses d'autres
pays et je crois que ça c'est très
important aussi le sujet est mondial
Emmanuel Macron a dit on peut pas faire
bien sûr sans les États-Unis sans la
Chine les plus gros pollueurs ceux qui
nous ne nous exonère pas de faire bien
sûr des efforts Thomas dessus oui mais
alors pour faire la leçon aux autres
pays il faut pouvoir être exemplaire
quoi que ce soit et actuellement c'est
pas le cas on n'est pas mauvais
un engagement qui a été pris par la
France l'année dernière à Glasgow la
Coop de Glasgow pareil la France a fait
des belles déclarations a pris un
engagement important de réduire de 30 %
les émissions de méthane qu'est-ce qui a
été fait depuis un an pour réduire les
émissions de méthane française qu'est-ce
qui a été fait pour encadrer et limiter
l'élevage intensif par exemple qui est
un écran des émetteurs de méthane rien
rien n'a été fait pour limiter les
émissions de méthane donc on peut faire
des grandes déclarations quand
Emmanuel Macron dit on va repousser
l'objectif à -50% des missions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030 nous l'avions
proposé il y a un an deux ans lors de la
loi climat qui était avec un objectif de
moins 40% nous avions dit déjà c'est cet
objectif est insuffisant l'Europe va
réhausser réhaussons tout de suite nos
objectifs la France n'est jamais au
rendez-vous quand il faut passer à
l'action concrète c'est ça le problème
un exemple simple vous l'aviez dit vous
comptiez le faire comment et bien parce
que le vrai sujet c'est le même discours
que le président chira est bien encore
aujourd'hui il faut il faut mais vous le
faisiez au moment de la loi climat nous
avions propos un centre d'amendement qui
permettait nous laver nous avions tout
chiffré nous avions un projet de loi
climat de vrais loi climat qui
permettait d'atteindre ces - 5% moins
55% des missions de gaz à effet de serre
en fermant les centrales etc ça ne
marche pas mais bien sûr
de RTE il y a au moins deux scénarios
qui permettent de se passer du nucléaire
sortie par RTL papa par des par des
conditions qui permet de se passer du
nucléaire et de réduire ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et de réinitialiser
la France Jérôme bachel le vrai sujet
c'est est-ce qu'on arrive à faire cette
transition sans ces personnes
entre-temps car hélas les solutions que
vous avez proposées massacrer
complètement des situations économiques
ici et là et reprenez le rapport qui
vient de sortir hier de Jean Pisani
ferries l'économiste qui est un ami
d'ailleurs bon je peux le dire qui est
le conseiller d'Emmanuel Macron et
pourtant nous n'avons jamais partagé les
mêmes options politiques il explique
très bien dans ce rapport combien il va
être difficile le décarboner quel est le
coût colossal qu'il faut s'apprêter à
faire et c'est une véritable bombe c'est
dans le journal Le Monde d'aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'il faut faire derrière les
paroles en disant il y a une
transactions le président de la
République a encore fait des annonces et
moi je suis assez d'accord avec Céline
Dion là-dessus c'est bien beau de faire
des annonces à condition de les
respecter on le respecte pas sur les
déficits comme on l'annonce on le
respecte pas non plus sur le gaz donc
sur le CH4 le méthane pardon et donc il
faut que nous passions effectivement
mais c'est il faut pas faire des
déclarations il faut donner le plan
complet et les années et les tracer et
les tenir d'année en année quand on
commence pas par respecter sa parole la
première année c'est plus difficile pour
après faire la marche d'après ah c'est
donc assez contradictoire avec le
discours qu'a tenu tout à l'heure Bruno
Le Maire dans l'hémicycle il a été
interrogé sur la question de la
décarbonation de l'industrie et il a
raconté bien une histoire dans dans
l'hémicycle on va écouter un extrait de
l'intervention de Bruno Le Maire
je vais vous raconter une histoire
[Musique]
à dormir debout
une histoire à rêver debout
c'est celle du site de Solvay que l'on
visiter ce matin avec le ministre de
l'Industrie Roland Lescure un site qui a
un siècle d'histoire industrielle
derrière lui ainsi qui produit des
produits chimiques du carbonate de soude
du bicarbonate de soude avec comme
énergie du charbon importé de Russie
ainsi donc émet beaucoup de CO2 qui a
des problèmes de compétitivité et qui
aujourd'hui ne répond plus au standards
les plus innovants et à nos exigences
environnementales ce site est en train
d'opérer une révolution climatique et
industrielle cette histoire a rêvé
debout elle doit être l'histoire de tous
les grands sites industriels français et
notamment des 56 industriels que le
Président de la République a choisi
auquel nous allons apporter 5 milliards
d'euros d'aide immédiatement et 5
milliards d'euros d'aide complémentaires
si jamais nous suivent dans cet objectif
de décarbonation pour que nous ayons
demain l'industrie mondiale
la plus décarbonée de la planète
c'est une idée de bout à laquelle vous
croyez Thomas dessus non mais c'est
intéressant c'est un même un revirement
parce que globalement ce qu'ils font ce
que Bruno Le Maire a annoncé ce qui
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé hier c'est ce
qu'on demande depuis très longtemps
c'est-à-dire de conditionner les aides
publiques à des résultats notamment en
matière de de décarbonation de de
l'industrie vous êtes satisfait mais on
est satisfait de la méthode en tout cas
de dire des industries on vous aidera si
vous arrivez à atteindre les objectifs
qu'on vous fixe c'est ce qu'on demandait
au moment du plan de relance ou Bruno Le
Maire balayait toutes ces conditions
d'un revers de main et maintenant il
arrive à ce sujet là c'est à dire que
oui on peut plus déverser des milliards
dettes publiques sans demander aux
entreprises aussi de changer et
d'évoluer donc oui pour nous c'est
important est-ce que c'est encore au bon
niveau on sent on le verra on n'a pas on
n'a pas encore exactement la trajectoire
et en plus les industries qui étaient
qui étaient appelés à à l'Élysée c'était
toutes les industries très polluantes
sauf les producteurs d'énergie c'est à
dire sauf les raffineries et sauf
d'autres énergies très populaire donc il
y a encore des problèmes Jérôme Bacher
10 milliards 70 milliards par an il faut
c'est ce que dit ce rapport que je vous
citais auparavant le contenu est pas 70
milliards par an d'investissement
nécessaire pour les entreprises et il y
a 10 milliards en une fois voilà bon
c'est insuffisant Martin lévrier 10
milliards si on écoute les uns les
autres et je peux bien l'entendre
simplement 10 milliards c'est déjà
quelque chose et surtout c'est 10
milliards dans une logique de plan sur
un cours moyen et long terme c'est pas
juste un one shot un coup qu'on fait
comme ça vite fait on repense
complètement la réindustrie les sons de
la France je rappelle malgré tout que si
on en est là si aussi qu'on l'a laissé
se désindustrialiser gentiment
tranquillement pendant 30 ans on y
revient et donc ce retard qu'on a pris à
tous les niveaux on essaie de le
rattraper aujourd'hui et c'était urgent
de le faire il faut bien le faire faut
le prendre par un bout leur dire c'est
jamais assez moi je réponds certes mais
si tu étais beaucoup plus intelligent de
le commencer bien avant et bah il y a un
an il y a deux ans il y a 15 ans non non
il vient de dire et je l'ai repris dans
ma question
le cice a été créé le non mais c'est pas
que ça le crédit pour recherche n'est
pas que vous voulez mettre des
conditions déjà à chaque fois on nous a
dit non il faut Limoges
du plan de relance c'est encore autre
100 m aucune condition c'était encore
autre chose alors c'était les conditions
elles ont été respectées puisque on a
une relance immédiate que non pas eu les
autres pays ce qui était ce qui était
l'objectif allez j'en viens à l'un des
autres temps forts et le troisième point
sur lequel nous allons terminer ce
débrief ce sujet c'est celui de la
situation des services de pédiatrie les
médecins ont tiré la semaine d'alarme
déjà depuis quelques jours quelques
semaines et bien aujourd'hui François
Braun a annoncé et bien le plan
hors-sant dans l'hémicycle qui est
déclenché le plan en blanc national
écouté
je peux vous assurer que l'ensemble des
moyens disponibles sont mobilisés pour
faire face à cette nouvelle crise et à
cette épidémie de bronchiolite santé
publique France d'ailleurs ce matin nous
indiquer que c'est une épidémie qui
dépasse les pics épidémiques que nous
avons connues depuis plus de 10 ans
d'ailleurs pour accompagner cette cette
information j'ai décidé ce matin en
complément de tout ce qui était déjà
mobilisé de déclencher le plan hors-sant
spécifique à cette épidémie pour
renforcer encore les moyens des ARS et
permettre que l'ensemble de l'hôpital
puisse se concentrer sur ce problème
particulièrement aigu aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre peut pas se cacher
derrière l'épidémie de bronchiolite pour
parler des problèmes actuels vous avez
fait des choix et ses choix il faut
maintenant les assumer vous avez décidé
de faire porter les 17,7 milliards
d'euros de la dette covid sur la
sécurité sociale créant cette année sont
déficit vous avez décidé d'exonération
de cotisation qui sont passées en 5 ans
de 39 à 71 milliards mais vous refusez
dans le même temps toutes les
propositions que nous avons pu vous
faire pour trouver de nouvelles recettes
c'est donc que vous faites le choix
délibéré du déficit pour la sécurité
sociale et ce peut-être ou sans doute au
profit du système privé but lucratif et
réaction au déclenchement de ce plan
horsant annonce lors de la séance de
questions au gouvernement du ministre de
la Santé Philippe mouillé qui est au
micro d'Alexandre Poussard
le gouvernement qui déclenche le plan
hors-sant pour concentrer les moyens de
l'hôpital notamment sur la lutte contre
cette épidémie de bronchiolite c'est une
mesure qui va dans le bon sens après les
enveloppes budgétaires qui ont été
annoncés à ces dernières semaines oui
c'est une mesure qui va dans le bon sens
mais ce que l'on regrette c'est le
manque d'anticipation il faut l'examen
d'appel FSS pour que nous ayons non pas
préalablement plusieurs semaines avant
mais au fur et à mesure des allocentes
nouvelles comme si le on était dans le
sentiment d'avoir un bateau qui coule et
au fur et à mesure on met des rustines
pour pouvoir garder à flot voilà donc
c'est initiative de bar donc dans le bon
sens mais vraiment vraiment on a besoin
d'une vision globale d'une stratégie et
surtout de l'anticipation cette
réflexion stratégique le ministre de la
Santé François Brown l'a dit elle va
apprendre du temps notamment dans le
cadre du Conseil national de la
refondation sur la partie santé donc
finalement est-ce que vous saluez cette
double action du gouvernement à la fois
sur le court terme et sur le long terme
alors je crois que d'abord il y a
urgence qui se met en place mais on peut
aller beaucoup plus vite nous avons nous
un certain nombre de proposition en
matière de réforme réorganisation et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut continuer à
consulter globalement si on doit aller
et donc tout ça c'est beaucoup de
communication il y a urgence de trouver
à la fois des moyens financiers de
revoir l'organisation et surtout d'avoir
un regard géré très pragmatique terrain
des besoins de la population justement
sur les moyens financiers et cette
enveloppe de 600 millions d'euros qui a
été annoncé cette semaine dans le cadre
de l'examen du budget de la Sécurité
sociale pour soutenir les services en
tension notamment les services de
pédiatrie certains sénateurs dit 10
c'est même pas financier n'est même pas
de nouvelles recettes enfin de cette
nouvelle dépense donc c'est un tour de
passe budgétaire oui oui on le pense
alors d'ailleurs on sait pas trop parce
que on ne annonce que finalement ces 400
millions d'euros qui resteraient du
budget 2022 complété on n'a pas de
visibilité on a demandé d'avoir un
tableau clair de la provenance de ces
sommes financières voilà et au-delà de
tout ça j'ai ressenti 600 millions
d'euros mais c'est pas ce qui va former
des pédiatres ça permet peut-être de
donner des quais combien de financer
supplémentaire mais aujourd'hui c'est
des moyens humains ce sont des
compétences dont on a besoin donc de
nouveau ce n'est pas en réagissant en
mettant simplement de l'argent quoi
général problème il faut à la fois voir
cette capacité financière mais surtout
avoir une anticipation de l'organisation
et bien finalement de nos services on
évoquait tout à l'heure aux femmes on
évoquait les fermetures de lit les
fermes de liste c'est pas qu'un sujet
financier c'est parce que nous n'avons
plus de personnel compétents plus
personnel formé que nous on est parfois
obligé de faire des délits donc on a
vraiment besoin de non pas régler la
santé par un bel effet c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire aujourd'hui mais
régler la santé par une loi
d'orientation et surtout d'une noix de
programmation merci beaucoup Philippe
mouiller donc des solutions à long terme
et puis également des solutions
d'urgence pour faire face à cette
épidémie de bronchiolite merci merci
beaucoup Alexandre on va commencer par
parler de ce plan d'urgence ce plan
hors-sant qui a été déclenché face à
l'épidémie de bronchiolite qui est la
plus grave depuis une dizaine d'années
Martin lévriers et puis ces enveloppes
qu'on a vu grossir au fur et à mesure
qu'on a vu l'épidémie grossir
50 millions 400 millions d'euros
débloqués et puis finalement c'est 550
millions d'euros est-ce qu'il y a un
manque d'anticipation un manque de
stratégie c'est ce que dit Philippe
mouiller Martin lévrier il y a deux
choses d'abord il dit que c'est une
bonne idée et après effectivement on
parle de manque d'anticipation mais moi
je ne savais pas que le virus de la
bronchiolite attendait le vote du PLFSS
pour se déclencher en français je vais
il y a un moment quand on connaît un peu
le monde médical on sait très bien que
malheureusement face à des épidémies de
ce type là quand elles arrivent si elles
sont plus violentes que d'habitude il
faut plus de moyens mais le prévoir six
mois avant un an avant 2 ans avant je ne
connais pas un médecin qui oserait dire
en 2024 en septembre 2024 il y aura une
épidémie quelques semaines que les
professionnels de santé alerte sur le
fait alors c'est un encore un sujet
connexe j'allais dire mais si ils
alertent sur le fait comme tout le monde
hospitalier sur la pénurie de personnel
dans le monde hospitalier mondial et
français l'épidémie de brocoli commence
et effectivement comme c'est eux qui
sont en tension ils le disent plus vite
que les autres mais c'est bien normal
qu'il soit en choisir c'est bien normal
qu'ils alert parce qu'effectivement la
bronchite ça fait à peu près un mois que
nous l'avons que nous l'avons dans le
pays et dès le départ comme elle a été
très violente très brutale
violente immédiate donc cet ensemble de
choses comme nous étions en tension de
personnel et comme nous sommes en train
de personnel mais comme le monde entier
dans son personnel médical ça on peut en
parler autant qu'on veut et bien oui il
a bien fallu tout de suite réagir et
heureusement que le gouvernement a réagi
on augmentant de 4 de 600 millions
d'euros d'ailleurs les budgets pour
développer des moyens pour répondre à
cette urgence Thomas do Suez que c'est
la bonne réponse que celle du
gouvernement aujourd'hui face à cette
épidémie de bronchiolite alors que je
rappelle steder d'ailleurs le débat que
l'on faisait au tout début des questions
au gouvernement il y a un énorme
problème de de notamment qui concerne la
pédiatrie de désert médical de manque de
personnel l'hôpital Necker c'est la
moitié des délits qui sont fermés
globalement si on peut ce que vous nous
dites c'est qu'en fait l'hôpital public
ne peut plus absorber une épidémie
bronchiolite c'est ça que vous nous
dites et avant l'été on se demandait si
les urgences allaient pouvoir absorber
la crise covid on se demandait c'est les
urgences des
urgences françaises
à chaque fois le prix mais chaque
séquence épidémique fait trembler
l'hôpital public parce que là peut-être
publique a été ravagé par des
différentes réformes libérales on a
fermé le nombre de lit le Ségur alors on
nous a parlé du Ségur après on a du
printemps on va voir les assises de la
pédiatrie on a le CNR on on est on est
toujours dans le dans l'urgence ou dans
des plans pour gérer ce qui a été mal
géré pendant des années on prend des
mesures vous le reconnaissez
heureusement
qu'il laisse pas l'hôpital public dans
l'état où il est dans l'état d'urgence
dans lequel il est heureusement mais
c'est les mesures d'urgence il y a rien
de structurelle Jérôme
c'est payer des heures supplémentaires
au médecin urgentiste pédiatrique pour
pouvoir accueillir dans l'hôpital public
et faire qui qui fasse plus d'heures
voilà ce que c'est parce que faut quand
même parler en français et dire que
c'est juste payer les heures
supplémentaires qui sont usées
question d'actualité au Gouvernement
nous y sommes que nous avons dit à
Monsieur Braun attention les pays
brocolites nous ne sommes pas prêts et
il nous a répondu mais non passé vous
êtes on regarde on est vigilant alors
que déjà déjà des bébés étaient
transportés des bébés étaient
transportés dans d'autres régions que
l'Île-de-France qui était saturée déjà à
100 km à Reims